zu beurteilen wie man in der
vergangenheit mit russland oder
bedrohungslagen umgegangen ist die
ukraine ist kein nato-land insofern
stellt sich eine kriegerische frage in
diesen tagen sowieso nicht
wir wissen derzeit viele menschen setzen
sich in bewegung um sich in sicherheit
zu bringen polen zum beispiel bereitet
sich schon auf die aufnahme zahlreicher
flüchtlinge vor wie sehen denn ihre wie
sehen die deutschen planungen dazu aus
wir sind natürlich sehr wachsam und auch
vorbereitet auf all das was da jetzt
kommt und ich darf mich vor allen dingen
bei den bundesländern bedanken die sich
gut vorbereiten und auch bei den städten
und kommunen die gestern schon ihre
hilfe angeboten haben falls die
fluchtbewegungen dann auch deutschland
erreichen werden jetzt geht es erstmal
darum vor allen dingen die nachbarländer
der ukraine zu unterstützen dieses
furchtbare leid was den menschen dort im
moment geschieht da gilt meine
anteilnahme denjenigen die in der
letzten nacht verstorben sind haben sie
denn schon irgendwelche
zahlen dazu wie viele flüchtlinge es
sich den handel könnte nein das können
wir noch überhaupt nicht absehen die
einzige zahl die bislang existiert
bezieht sich auf die ukraine selber und
hat sie er geht im moment davon aus dass
innerhalb der ukraine hunderttausend
flüchtlinge sich auf den weg gemacht
haben aber das betrifft tatsächlich im
moment nur die ukraine selbst und frau
fischer ich muss an dieser stelle noch
einmal nachfragen weil sie es gerade
selber schon ins spiel gebracht haben
die frage nach deutschen waffen für die
ukraine denn die forderungen werden
natürlich angesichts dieser neuen
eskalierenden lage doch wieder lauter
unter anderem vor etwa einer stunde auch
von sigmar gabriel nein wir sind nicht
für waffenlieferungen in die ukraine da
hat sich auch nichts daran geändert
nancy faeser war das bisher in vielen
dank erstmal wir reden gleich nochmal
weiter vorher aber beschäftigen wir uns
mit der cyber sicherheit und zwar tun
wir das weil das auch etwas mit dem
krieg jetzt in der ukraine zu tun hat
hier erst einmal die information dazu
gut dieser beitrag liegt im moment nicht
vor den reichen wir später noch mal nach
hier bei uns im programm aber
bundesinnenministerium entweder ist uns
natürlich weiter zugeschaltet und sie
beschäftigen sich selbstverständlich als
innenministerin mit diesem thema deshalb
können wir auch mit ihnen jetzt darüber
sprechen ja für wie groß halten sie denn
die gefahr dieses cyber gefahr seitens
russlands auch für unsere infrastruktur
und sicherheit wir gehen davon aus dass
cyber angriffen natürlich auch ein
kriegerisches mittel sind das wird sich
in erster linie erstmal auf die ukraine
beziehen aber selbstverständlich sind
wir auch wachsam und sehr aufmerksam und
vorbereitet was mögliche cyberangriffe
auf die bundesrepublik betreffen
deswegen haben sich die
sicherheitsbehörden dort auch schon sehr
gut vorbereitet und wir werden im moment
bündeln wir alle maßnahmen der
sicherheitsbehörden in einem cyber
kompetenzzentrum um dort auch gewappnet
zu sein falls was zu sehen ist weil
mögliche ziele sind vor allen dingen aus
der kritischen infrastruktur anzunehmen
was kann man denn daraus ableiten
perspektive schon langfristig gesehen
droht uns womöglich bald ja eine art
richtiger ist cyber krieg zwischen
russland und dem westen
also das kann man natürlich nicht
vorhersagen aber ich glaube dass man
generell auf cyberangriffe heutzutage
anders vorbereitet sein müssen deswegen
bin ich auch froh dass wir das bsi haben
das amt für bundes sicherheit im cyber
bereich und uns da auch aufgestellt
haben ich denke generell geheimen eine
verlagerung auch der ich sag mal
alltagskriminalität in netze insofern
ist es für die zukunft 1 der team
worüber wir uns am meisten kümmern
müssen und auch am meisten vorbereiten
müssen nancy faeser war dass die
bundesinnenministerium vielen dank für
dieses interview an diesem freitagmorgen
hier morgenmagazin dankeschön sehr gerne
wir wollen den blick auf diese krise
weiten einen europapolitischen blick
darauf werfen und sprechen jetzt mit dem
luxemburgischen außenministers jean
asselborn und sagen einen guten morgen
hallo
guten morgen hessen
es gibt jetzt viele thesen viele
theorien hätte man das was jetzt
eingetreten es sind irgendeiner form
verhindern können was ist ihre meinung
also es ist unheimlich schwierig mit
autokraten zivilisiert umzugehen und
putin ist ein mensch der ich habe das
selbst erlebt der von demokraten anfang
der 2000er jahre immer mehr zu einem
autokraten wurde und jetzt so ein
kriegstreiber das ist also unheimlich
schwierig analyse jetzt zu machen die
europäische union hat alle bemühungen
gemacht mit den amerikanern mit der nada
mit dem nato-russland-rat mit der osze
um putin zu warnen putin abzuhalten
davon sogar putin ein gespräch
anzubieten über die
sicherheitsarchitektur
in europa und die antwort war krieg
viele sagen viele schreiben das war eine
die chronik eines angekündigten krieges
weil putin so oft gewarnt hat und jetzt
reagiert man relativ kalt erwischt wie
sollte denn die eu auf das vorgehen
russlands reagieren ihrer
regierungschefin battle habt schon
gesagt europa müsse bereit sein einen
preis zu bezahlen welchen preis müssen
wir bezahlen
ja also wir sind ja als europäer auch in
der nato nicht in der lage militärisch
uns entgegen zu stellen denn das für die
dimension eines krieges noch viel
erhöhen und die nationen gesagt dass er
sein land ist mit einer atomwaffe das
hat er angekündigt darum haben wir die
mittel die wir angesetzt haben zuerst um
die diplomatie zu verteidigen und dann
das zweite ist natürlich dann die
reaktionen die sanktionen und hier sind
sanktionen die glaube ich weltweit noch
nie so tief greifend fahren zum beispiel
dass die russische
russland praktisch vom finanzsystem
abgeschnitten ist dass keine russische
bank mehr geschäfte machen kann in euro
oder dollar das geht sehr weit die
russische
flugzeug flotte ist zu zwei drittel
abhängig von den usa und von der
europäischen union zu kommen kein ersatz
stücke mehr natürlich auch in der
informatik und in wir sehr sehr
wichtigen bereich und auch fast die
ölforderung zum beispiel angeht all
diese
equipment die russland nicht irgendwo
anders zu kaufen bekommt wenn die nicht
mehr da sind dann wird russland nicht
mehr dass russland seien auch was es vor
diesen krieg war in diesem moment wird
die ukraine angegriffen wird die
hauptstadt kiew angegriffen attackiert
der außenminister spricht von
raketenbeschuss und das hätte man das
letzte mal 1941 von den nazis erlebt der
ukrainische präsident seelands gerhard
vor wenigen minuten noch eine
videobotschaft veröffentlicht da sagte
ich bleibe in der hauptstadt bleibe bei
meinem volk ich bin das hauptziel und er
beschwert sich eigentlich über den
westen die würden aus der ferne
sanktionen beschließen würden
solidarität bekunden aber das reiche
nicht aus um entschlossen den feind vom
heimischen boden zu vertreiben was wie
kann man der ukraine überhaupt noch
helfen
ich verstehe diese ganze
und diese schreckliche situation wo
präsenz allens gedreht ist außenminister
drin ist das ganze ukrainische volk ist
in dieser lage aber sehen sie ich das
ist ja die die kapitale frage dass
dieser putin das ausschlachtet das
militärisch wir da nicht einschreiten
können sonst stehen amerikaner gegen
russen deutsche oder franzosen gegen
russen ja ein bisschen entschuldigung
entschuldigung dass ich sie herr
asselborn eine letzte frage noch zum
finanzsystems mit diesem internationalen
das wird ja jetzt aufgefordert von den
ukrainischen politikern dass man das
doch jetzt bitte wenigstens umsätzen
möge aber auch da wehrt man sich
deutschland tut dies auch was ist ihre
meinung zur schrift
also ich glaube das trifft ist nicht vom
tisch wir haben heute mittag sind die
außenminister zusammen wenn diese
bombardierung von kiews weiter geht wenn
der präsident des events geben sein
leben fürchten muss ich glaube dann
kommt alles auf den tisch man muss nur
wissen wen man trifft wenn man mit
schrift die trifft die man treffen will
bin ich total einverstanden aber das ist
natürlich auch eine frage die nicht mit
ja oder mit nein zu beantworten ist das
was wir jetzt gemacht haben glaube ich
ist schon sehr sehr stark und es ist
nicht allein swift wir uns darauf
konzentrieren sollen die das abschneiden
von den finanzmärkten wird russland sehr
sehr weh tun und wird nicht mehr
funktionieren können wie ein normales
land lassen ist das was beschlossen
wurde und was natürlich sagen dass nur
einmal ausbaufähig ist wenn zum beispiel
heute mittag studie aus münster zusammen
kommen sagt der luxemburger
außenminister jean asselborn vielen dank
hat sich zeit genommen haben danke
bitte
ja mit rhi soweit die reaktionen aus dem
ausland und auch in deutschland gab es
am abend ja noch eine ansprache des
bundeskanzlers putin wird nicht gewinnen
das war wohl die deutlichste botschaft
ja auch hier ist man entschieden hatte
sanktionen gegen russland volle
solidarität mit der ukraine die reaktion
aus deutschland fasst jan fritsche für
sie und uns zusammen
für die demonstranten gestern vor dem
kanzleramt ist klar was zu tun ist putin
stoppen mit maximalen sanktionen gegen
russland und waffenlieferungen an die
ukraine
eine ukrainische flagge auch im
kanzleramt doch viel mehr als
solidarität will der hausherr dem land
nicht zu sagen betont stattdessen in
einer fernsehansprache der krieg dürfe
sich nicht weiter ausdehnen
putin sollte die entschlossenheit der
nato nicht unterschätzen alle ihre
mitglieder zu verteidigen das gilt
ausdrücklich für unsere nato partner im
baltikum in polen und in rumänien in
bulgarien und in der slowakei ohne wenn
und aber
außenministerin bernburg wirft putin im
zdf-interview wahnvorstellungen vor sie
und kanzler stolz sein von ihm angelogen
worden daneben fordert die grüne
außenministerin eine bessere ausstattung
fürs militär
wir erleben aber wenn wir die bundeswehr
anschauen zum beispiel dass er mit blick
auf material natürlich deutlich deutlich
mehr machen müssen deutlich mehr machen
das sieht beim thema verteidigung auch
der bundesfinanzminister so in der
vergangenheit sei die truppe
vernachlässigt worden
es gab eine friedensdividende das heißt
wir hatten nach dem ende des kalten
krieges das gefühl das brauchen wir
nicht mehr andere übernehmen die lasten
etwa die vereinigten staaten die union
hat sich an tag eins des krieges hinter
den kurs der ampel regierung gestellt
nur beim thema waffenlieferungen gibt es
bei manch einem einen sinneswandel
es ist jetzt richtig weil nicht mehr
gesprochen wird dass auch deutschland
die ukraine durch lieferung von
militärischer ausrüstung unterstützt in
der deutschen politik hat ein umdenken
begonnen beim umgang mit autoritären
staaten doch für die ukraine dürfte das
zu spät kommen
ja und herzzerreißende szenen spielen
sich in der ukraine ab familien die hals
über kopf ihr zuhause verlassen und nur
mit dem nötigsten richtung polen flehen
und auch schon geflohen sind natürlich
andere verzweifelte die in großstädten
wie kiew im metrosystem schutz suchen
die bilder haben wir auch schon gesehen
heute morgen oder die mit ihren liebsten
in ländliche gebiete flächen und dann
gibt es natürlich auch viele männer die
im land bleiben und als reservisten die
ukrainische armee unterstützen und all
diese brennenden sorgen hat auch die
ukrainische community hier in
deutschland circa 130.000 leben in
deutschland die fiebern mit die zittern
mit ihren verwandten und freunden in der
ukraine und aus bayern jetzt 27
sie demonstrieren für einen frieden den
es nicht mehr gibt mehr als 2000
menschen gehen gestern abend in nürnberg
auf die straße viele von ihnen stammen
aus der ukraine
sie haben freunde und verwandte die
jetzt im krieg leben
das ist das schlimmste was ich in meinem
leben erlebt habe weil ich nicht weiß
wie es weitergeht und eigentlich ist es
aussichtslos weil wir sehen dass keine
helfen kann was tun wenn die alte heimat
brennt die einen hoffen auf die kraft
der straße andere suchen hoffnung im
gebet
in münchen hat der pfarrer der
ukrainischen katholischen gemeinde zum
gottesdienst geladen beten was sollen
sie sonst auch tun von überall in der
ukraine erhalten sie jetzt verzweifelte
nachrichten
das ist eine große verunsicherung dass
es
viel angst beim fliegen die flugzeuge
militärflugzeuge überall hört man die
bomben also das ist ein schreckliches
szenario viele hier haben mit dem krieg
gerechnet und trotzdem sind sie jetzt
schockiert sie fühlen trauer und
unsicherheit und wut auf putin
[Musik]
eindeutig was verteidigt der einsitzer
was ich machen kann das ist ja jetzt
beten und einfach meine solidarität zu
zeigen
und um ihre leitung nicht
es gibt wenig hoffnung in der
ukrainischen gemeinde in deutschland und
bei vielen auch wenig vertrauen in die
reaktion des westens
dass sanktionen kommen jetzt wie oft
kommen sie zu spät
schon in unseren städten und
schießen und es wird getötet und
gemordet sie fühlen sich wie gelähmt
erzählen manche handlungsunfähig und
hoffnungslos bei keiner weiß wie das
alles endet
und jetzt live aus berlin das zdf
morgenmagazin
[Musik]
heute im studio variiert von waldenfels
und mitri sirin in liebe zuschauerinnen
und zuschauer wir begrüßen sie ganz
herzlich und kurz vor halb neun an
diesem freitag und wenn sie gerade erst
eingeschaltet haben dann werden wir sie
jetzt auf den aktuellen stand der dinge
bringen
denn sie wissen seit gestern nacht
herrscht krieg in europa das sind hier
aktuelle bilder russische panzer die
richtung auch ihr k vor rollen also
das wird wahrscheinlich in diesen
minuten genauso passieren dort wir
können das natürlich jetzt nicht genau
wie rififi zieren aber es gibt dutzende
solcher videos im internet gerade hab
gerade gestern nacht gesagt meinte
natürlich vorgestern nacht wir haben
noch weitere bilder die wir ihnen zeigen
wollen und zwar aufnahmen handy
aufnahmen die es bei twitter gab
[Musik]
da sehen sich menschen mut zu in irgend
einem luftschutzbunker in der ukraine
wir können nicht sagen wo das ist und
vermutlich passiert das in vielen
städten des landes aktuell es gibt viele
verschiedene aspekte die wir heute
vormittag beleuchten eine große ausgabe
des morgenmagazins bis 10.30 sind mir
heute aus aktuellem anlass haben
verschiedene aspekte wie gesagt wir
beleuchten und natürlich mehrere
gesprächs passte also die telefondrähte
laufen heißt nicht nur in der diplomatie
und in der politik sondern auch bei uns
wir versuchen unsere korrespondentinnen
und korrespondenten in verschiedensten
städten zu erreichen und haben viele
gespräche geführt und werden sie weiter
führen zum beispiel gerade im top thema
die bundesinnenministerium von der spd
nancy faeser die ihre sicht der dinge
geschildert hat der luxemburgische
außenminister war gerade mit uns im
gespräch und hat die europapolitische
situation eingeschätzt noch weiter
werden wir sprechen mit dem designierten
fdp generalsekretär des 3 und auch mit
dem außenpolitischen sprecher links der
linksfraktion gregor gysi all das hier
im zdf morgenmagazin
jetzt gibt es einen kurzen nachrichten
überblick zusammengefasst in der heute
express und die präsentiert peanut an
ricoh lohn hallo nochmal
guten morgen und auch ihnen liebe
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer guten
morgen die ukrainische armee liefert
sich nach angaben des generalstabs
heftige gefechte mit russischen truppen
in der nähe von kiew der ukrainische
aussenminister koller spricht außerdem
von raketenbeschuss in der hauptstadt
twitter videos sollen einschläge zeigen
wohnhäuser stehen in flammen
zahlreiche einwohner der stadt haben die
nacht in u-bahnhöfen verbracht nach
angaben von präsident selent ski sind
bislang 137 ukraine getötet und mehr als
300 verletzt worden angaben über tote
auf russischer seite gibt es bisher
nicht
im laufe des tages rechnet die
ukrainische regierung mit
panzerangriffen auf kiew ein berater des
innenministers schrieb auf telegramm die
verteidiger stunden mit abwehrraketen
bereit präsident salih hat bereits eine
komplette generalmobilmachung angeordnet
männliche start bürger im alter von 18
bis 60 dürfen demnach das land nicht
mehr verlassen
us-außenminister blinken geht davon aus
dass russlands präsident putin die
ukrainische regierung stürzen will am
abend kündigte us-präsident beiden an
7000 weitere soldaten nach europa zu
verlegen die zunächst in deutschland
stationiert werden sollen diese würden
aber nicht in der ukraine kämpfen
sondern die nato-verbündeten verteidigen
immer mehr länder weltweit verhängen
sanktionen gegen russland in der eu
haben sich die staats und
regierungschefs am abend auf
strafmassnahmen geeinigt sie beziehen
sich auf die bereiche energie finanzen
und transport
die finanz sanktionen zielen auf 70
prozent des russischen bankenmarkt
das ursprünglich von der bundesregierung
für ende januar angepeilte corona im
ziel wird nach schätzungen des
krisenstabs wohl erst im april erreicht
werden geplant waren dafür weitere 30
millionen impfungen skeptiker wolle man
mit einer einheitlichen
informationskampagne erreichen so der
gremiums leiter breuer in der
frankfurter allgemeinen zeitung und der
blick auf die aktuellen corona zahlen
1743 neuinfektionen wurden dem
robert-koch-institut binnen 24 stunden
gemeldet
9305 weniger als vor einer woche
226 todesfälle kamen dazu die sieben
tage incidents sinkt weiter auf 1.200
59,5
und auf welches wetter wir uns
einstellen müssen dass verrät uns
benjamin stufe
donnerwetter das wetter wird ihnen
präsentiert von bett1 de
vielen dank tina und guten morgen liebe
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer herzlich
willkommen zum wetter wir blicken direkt
auf die iso barren karte und können
sehen der hochdruckeinfluss vom atlantik
über die biskaya in unsere richtung der
nimmt zu das beschert uns ab morgen sehr
freundliches sehr sonniges und trockenes
wetter heute allerdings dominiert noch
mal der tiefdruckeinfluss ausgelöst
durch die tiefdruckgebiete über
skandinavien aprilwetter heute am
freitag und auch schon in den
vergangenen 12 stunden der radar film
fasst die nacht zusammen zwischen einem
und zehn liter regen auf den
quadratmeter gab es in den nördlichen
mittelgebirgen war es auch schnee im
moment schneit noch richtung erzgebirge
thüringer wald und auch am alpenrand die
temperaturen zum start in den tag
aktuell gemessen minus drei grad heute
morgen in kaufbeuren fünf grad sind es
auf borkum minus drei bis plus fünf das
ist die spanne die den tag eröffnet und
der beginnt durchaus mit sonnenschein in
einer großen kurve von der ostsee bis
zum schwarzwald im südosten verklingen
die letzten schneeschauer der nacht
allerdings werden von westen auch schon
die wolken dichter zum nachmittag ist es
dann flächendeckend da dieses april
wetter mit regen schnee graupel und auch
dem einen oder dem anderen gewitter im
umfeld dieser gewitter durchaus
stürmische böen und überhaupt heute noch
mal sehr lebhafter wind der sorgt auch
dafür dass die wolkendecke immer mal
aufreißt und sich die sonne blicken
lässt allerdings sind diese momente eher
von kurzer dauer das ganze bei
tageshöchsttemperaturen heute zwischen
drei grad richtung östlichen
mittelgebirge und am alpenrand bis 10
grad richtung oberrhein und damit sind
wir bei den hochdruck geprägten
aussichten für die kommenden drei tage
die schneeschauer verklingen morgen noch
im südosten und dann wird es von tag zu
tag sonniger und trockener und auch
milder am montag tageshöchsttemperaturen
zwischen 4 und 12 grad soweit zum wetter
für den moment kommen sie jetzt gut
endet freitag
donnerwetter das wetter wurde ihnen
präsentiert von bett1 de
guten morgen von uns beiden ist es auch
heute ein schwerer morgen bedrückende
stunden vor allen dingen natürlich für
die menschen aus der ukraine russland
hat die sicherheitsarchitektur in europa
mit diesem angriff verändert die
russische armee rückt weiter auf care
for wir sehen und hören von explosionen
in der nacht und am frühen morgen
truppen die angeblich noch wenige
kilometer von der hauptstadt entfernt
sein sollen und die regierung rechnet
hat tatsächlich noch mit panzerangriffen
heute im laufe des tages und das führt
natürlich auch dazu dass sich unzählige
menschen in bewegung setzen um schutz
und sicherheit zu suchen und polen als
unmittelbares nachbarland ukraine zum
beispiel hat sich schon längst
vorbereitet viele viele flüchtlinge aus
der ukraine aufzunehmen ungefähr 50 60
kilometer entfernt von polen liegt in
der west ukraine liegt lemberg und dort
ist für uns lothar becker wir hören auch
dort gibt es
luftalarm gibt es besorgniserregende
szenen was erleben sie gerade
es soll hier in lemberg heute früh einen
sirenen alarm gegeben haben wir hier an
unserem standort in der stadtmitte haben
das nicht gehört
das bezieht sich dann wahrscheinlich
wenn es denn stattgefunden hat wenn
diese alarm stattgefunden hat bezieht er
sich wahrscheinlich wieder auf anlagen
eher außerhalb der stadt dort sind ja
drei militärstützpunkte die auch schon
gestern ziel russischer raketen angriffe
waren viel dramatischer und wirklich
dramatisch und krieg herrscht in und um
kiew in der nacht in den frühen
morgenstunden soll ein russisches
flugzeug von der ukrainischen flugabwehr
abgeschossen worden seien anwohner haben
mir berichtet dass sie gesehen haben
dass dieses flugzeug in privatgebäuden
abgestürzt ist es soll dort wohl drei
verletzte geben außerdem sollen
trümmerteile oder teile einer rakete in
einem apartmentblock eingeschlagen seien
der momentane stand in kiew scheint der
zu sein dass die russischen truppen
versuchen auf die hauptstadt vorzurücken
möglicherweise den flughafen einzunehmen
um dort einen militärischen brückenkopf
aufbauen zu können so weiteres gerät
direkt in richtung kiew zu bringen und
das scheint für meine einschätzung ein
klarer angriff in richtung der regierung
der ukraine zu sein die putins regime
bezeichnet da müssen wir die nächsten
stunden der entwicklung die
entwicklungen in den nächsten stunden
genau beobachten luther wir hören dass
zehntausende kiew verlassen also die
metropole und natürlich richtung westen
sich auf den weg machen zur polnischen
grenze die er nicht so weit von ihnen
entfernt ist oder möglicherweise auch
halt machen in lemberg weil sie dort
verwandte haben wie macht sich das bei
ihnen bemerkbar
wir beobachteten gestern und auch heute
dass menschen auch lemberg verlassen
menschen versuchen nicht zwingend direkt
das land zu verlassen aber sie versuchen
die großen städte zu verlassen sie
versuchen aus dem einzugsbereich von
militärstützpunkten sich zu entfernen um
eben auf dem land in kleinen dörfern bei
verwandten unterzukommen und die
nächsten aktionen abzuwarten die
nächsten tage und stunden gleichzeitig
ja die slowakei hat die grenzen in der
nacht geöffnet und so ist es also
menschen aus der ukraine problemlos
möglich auch ohne dokumente das land zu
verlassen das gilt aber nicht für die
wehrfähigen männer denn in der nacht gab
es ja die generalmobilmachung präsident
selensky hat alle männer zu den waffen
gerufen 18 bis ich meine 60 jährige
männer dürfen das land nicht mehr
verlassen es ging jetzt darum
zusammenzustehen ruhe zu bewahren auf
der einen seite sofern das möglich ist
auf der anderen seite sich den
territorialen verteidigungskräfte
anzuschließen um so dass weitere
vorrücken russischer truppen
möglicherweise verhindern zu können wir
haben heute morgen mehrfach zitiert den
ukrainischen präsidenten der
durchhalteparolen natürlich an sein volk
adressiert und sagt eigentlich bin ich
das hauptziel aber wir stehen zusammen
und wir müssen zusammenhalten was können
sie denn sagen zur militärischen
ausstattung oder behaupte wie es um das
ukrainische militär steht bekommen sie
davon in lemberg etwas mit
der hier direkt in der innenstadt von
lemberg nicht hier gibt es zwar truppen
fahrzeuge die durch die stadt fahren
aber das haben uns anwohner bestätigt
war auch schon vorher so man darf nicht
vergessen seit 2014 bereitet sich die
ukraine auf so einen tag iks vor
sicherlich war niemandem bewusst wie
gravierend und schnell und präzise
dieser russische angriff sein könnte
aber es war klar dass die situation
eskalieren kann und alle menschen mit
denen ich mich in den letzten wochen
unterhalten habe haben mir bestätigt wir
sind im krieg es ist nicht ein konflikt
der jetzt erst auf glaubt sondern er
existiert in den köpfen in den herzen
die ganze zeit entsprechend hat sich
auch das militär aufgestellt ich habe
mich mit einem kommandeur der luftwaffe
unterhalten vor dem beginn des
einmarsches und er sagte mir man sei auf
alles vorbereitet man habe die pläne man
warte nur noch auf das signal zu starten
und die luftwaffe war ja auch gestern
eines der ersten ziele die ganzen
luftwaffenstützpunkte in der ukraine
sind angegriffen und größtenteils wohl
auch zerstört worden ein ukrainisches
flugzeug so meldungen soll es über die
grenze nach rumänien geschafft haben
wurde dort von amerikanischen f 16
flugzeugen also flugzeugen
amerikanischer bauart dann sozusagen in
empfang genommen und konnte dort sicher
landen wenn also ukrainische
kampfflieger ins ausland fliegen müssen
um überhaupt wieder landen zu können
dann zeigt das doch wie gravierend
dieser erste schlag der russischen
truppen mit raketen auf
militärstützpunkte am ende war danke für
diese live informationen aus lemberg
lothar becker war dass ungefähr 60 70
kilometer entfernt von der polnischen
grenze und genau dorthin wollen wir
jetzt auch gehen nämlich nach polen und
uns die situation einordnen lassen es
ist wohl so dass sich zehntausende
aufmachen und auch schon sehr sehr viele
angekommen sind natalie steger ist für
uns im polnischen korso war das ist
direkt hinter der ukrainischen grenze
was können wir uns sagen aber flucht
flüchtlingsbewegungen
nun polen hat noch vor dem dieser
massiven offensive damit gerechnet dass
drei bis fünf millionen ukrainer kommen
das könnte natürlich jetzt noch mehr
menschen werden wir sind hier am
autobahnübergang sie haben es gesagt
wenn man sieht jetzt relativ ruhig aus
weil die autos nach darüber kommen aber
der polnische grenzschutz hat uns gesagt
noch mindestens 1000 warten warten auf
der anderen seite und zwei frauen die es
aus kaffee her geschafft haben die haben
zehn stunden gewartet wie sie hier
endlich über die grenze gehen konnten
aber die polnischen behörden die machen
es den menschen relativ leicht auch wenn
es manchmal eine halbe stunde oder eine
stunde dauert aber die menschen dürfen
selbst mit abgelaufenen reisepass ihr
einkommen also da ist es recht
unkompliziert und auch gestern am
bahnhof da wurden die menschen sehr
freundlich aufgenommen auch in der nacht
es sind hunderte mit den zügen aus kiew
gekommen die wurden erstversorgt man hat
sandwiches verteilt man hat ihnen
angeboten dass man sie weiter
transportiert die welle der
hilfsbereitschaft ist ziemlich groß auch
an den anderen übergängen wo die leute
zu fuß an kommen nur mit dem gepäck was
sie tragen konnten wir haben sich
privatleute angeboten haben gesagt wir
können euch weiter fahren die welle ist
ziemlich groß der hilfsbereitschaft
vielleicht können sie uns noch ein
bisschen einblicke geben in die
polnische politik polen muss ja
befürchten dass wladimir putin der
russische präsident die gesamte ukraine
einnimmt und dann im grunde ja auch an
der polnischen grenze steht wie wird
denn dieses szenario wahrgenommen und
wie wird das kommentiert
das szenario wird mit großem entsetzen
wahrgenommen die letzten jahre da dachte
man immer polen nato starter ist man
sicherlich nicht bedroht auch aus den
baltischen ländern haben wir das gehört
man hat im grunde nie ernsthaft gedacht
dass putin seine noch macht noch weiter
über die ukraine hinaus ausweiten will
aber es wird nun doch immer mehr gewarnt
es gibt stimmen nicht in der politik der
sagt moravetz geht der ministerpräsident
polen ist ein sicheres land noch aber
wenn sie mit den leuten sprechen da
macht man sich wirklich erstmals große
sorgen weil putin als einfach so
unberechenbar gilt vielen dank für diese
einschätzung live aus porsche war hinter
der ukrainischen grenze in polen natalie
steger war das vielen dank
so dann besprechen wir doch an dieser
stelle nochmal welches bild die
europäische union in dieser krise
aktuell insgesamt abgibt eu
kommissionspräsidenten ursula von der
leyen betonte nach einem krisentreffen
ja gestern putin werde scheitern
nach dem angriff wurde jetzt ein
massives sanktionspaket geschnürt dass
russlands wirtschaft und die finanzwelt
und dazu eben auch noch putin vertraute
hart treffen soll den schärfsten
sanktions weil nämlich den ausschluss
aus dem internationalen finanzsystem ist
swift den lässt man allerdings noch im
köcher und hier hat schon der
oppositionsführer nämlich friedrich merz
gesagt das müsse man aber bitte an
wänden nämlich ausgerechnet deutschland
sperrt sich offenbar noch dagegen mehr
erfahren wir von florian leu hand
es ist halb drei uhr heute früh als sie
in brüssel endlich auf die bühne treten
mit dabei frankreichs präsident makro
die am abend als erster westlicher
politiker nach dem angriff mit wladimir
putin telefoniert hatte
ich hatte einen offenen ehrlichen und
schnellen austausch mit dem präsidenten
putin auf wunsch des ukrainischen
präsidenten um putin um ein ende der
kämpfe zu bitten das hat wie sie sehen
für den moment zu nichts geführt
da pro ddp von wenigen stunden hatten
die staats und regierungschefs der eu
zuvor diskutiert zwischendrin
zugeschaltet der ukrainische präsident
zielinski wie scharf reagiert die eu ist
die frage die alles bestimmt der
slowenische premier mit krawatte in den
farben der ukraine verlangt mehr als nur
symbole
wir fordern die schärfsten sanktionen
gegen russland die möglich sind wir
reden jedoch nicht über wirtschaftsdaten
ob die inflation nun fünf oder sechs
prozent beträgt wir sprechen hier über
menschenleben
mit einem zweiten sanktionspaket will
europa jetzt die russische wirtschaft
treffen etwa mit export verboten bei
high tech produkten einschränkungen bei
der vergabe von visa oder dem einfrieren
von russischen vermögen in der eu
das paket enthält finanzaktionen die
russland vom zugang zu den wichtigsten
kapitalmärkten abschneiden wir zielen
damit auf 70 der russischen banken
eines aber fehlt in dem paket was zuvor
nicht nur der ukrainische aussenminister
lautstark gefordert hatte der ausschluss
russlands aus trifft trifft hier die
zentrale vor den toren brüssels ist das
zahlungssystem über das banken weltweit
überweisungen abwickeln ein ausschluss
wäre die härteste die waffe des westens
aber eine die auch europas wirtschaft
treffen würde und so bremst auch
deutschland gefragt danach will olaf
scholz die maßnahme lieber auf behalten
für eine situation wo das notwendig ist
auch noch andere dinge zu tun welche
situation er meint sagt scholz nicht in
der gipfelerklärung kein wort zuschrift
fragen wir nach bei guter zugeschaltet
jetzt aus brüssel verspricht denn für
einige mitgliedstaaten darunter eben
auch deutschland wie wir gehört haben
dagegen russland aus dem internationalen
zahlsystem swift auszuschließen
einer dieser mitgliedstaaten der hat das
gestern ganz deutlich gesagt der
österreichische bundeskanzler die hammer
sagte die aus der ausschluss russlands
von swift der wir die russische
föderation wahrscheinlich weniger stark
treffen als die europäische union selbst
der hat das so begründet erstens habe
russland sein eigenes zahlungssysteme
und zweitens könne es sich ganz schnell
dem chinesischen zahlungssystem
anschließen da sieht man dass die
dominanz von zwölfte im internationalen
zahlungsverkehr darunter eben auch
leiden könnte das mag stimmen dass es
auf der anderen seite aber auch eine
etwas bequeme these gerade für
österreich war gerade österreichische
banken stark in russland investiert sind
und die müssten dann besonders starke
zahlungsausfälle verkraften
deutschland geht das ganz ähnlich und
deswegen ist auch deutschland im club
der bremser dass es nicht unbedingt eine
sehr feine gesellschaft hat gehörte
ungarn dazu das ja in sachen sanktionen
wiederholten wackelkandidat war aber
auch zypern der sich regelmäßig den
vorwurf anhören muss dass seine banken
im grunde große geld waschmaschinen für
russisches schwarzgeld seien deswegen
gibt es eben auch kritik an dieser
position der bundesregierung auch aus
der ampel selbst aus dem europaparlament
ein grüner abgeordneter sagte wir zahlen
mit unseren gasrechnung ein teil dieses
russischen angriffskrieges und da
sollten wir auch bereits in den preis
dafür zu zahlen dass das aufhört
solidarität dass wir dem was kosten was
uns zu dem er noch beschäftigt ist die
reaktion der nato gunnar wie wird denn
aktuell die gefahr eingeschätzt dass
sich dieser krieg auch auf nato gebiet
noch ausweiten könnte
jedoch eher gering die nato trifft sich
heute zu einem virtuellen gipfel also
die staats- und regierungschefs der 30
mitgliedsstaaten
nato-generalsekretär jens stoltenberg
sagte gestern schon dass das man
natürlich gewillt sei jeden nato-staat
jedes nato-mitglied zu verteidigen
artikel 5 gilt dann natürlich für alle
wenn einer angegriffen wird dann sehen
dass alle als eine ein angriff auf alle
und das sollte eigentlich die
abschreckungswirkung genug sein aber er
sagt die eben auch ganz deutlich wir
verteidigen jeden mitgliedsstaat und wir
verteidigen eben im umkehrschluss muss
man es sagen kein land das kein
mitgliedstaat ist und das ist eben die
ukraine
gunnar krüger war das mit einer
einordnung live aus brüssel vielen dank
dafür
im studio bei mir und pariert ist den
ganzen morgen schon markus kaim er ist
sicherheitsexperte und
politikwissenschaftler bei der stiftung
wissenschaft und politik einen schönen
guten morgen herr kein morgen wir haben
heute schon diverse fragen an sie
gerichtet würde mich jetzt noch mal
interessieren für das thema schrift da
gibt es jetzt ja möglicherweise
differenzen in der deutschen haltung
erst hat friedrich merz gestern hier
noch im interview gesagt wir stehen an
der seite der bundesregierung
und wenn es doch eigentlich der
vorschlag von olaf scholz ist ein
stufenmodell was die sanktionierung
angeht zu behalten und den swift fall
erst später zu schießen und märz jetzt
aber sagt man müsste das jetzt sofort
machen was sagen sie
es markiert zwei dinge erstens der
innenpolitische druck der handlungsdruck
auf die bundesregierung stark
irgendetwas zu tun das hat natürlich
damit zu tun dass viele leute zum
erstmal die bedrohung wirklich
realisiert haben und dass die die bilder
von gestern
derart politischen schock gewirkt haben
bei uns allen aber natürlich gerade im
politischen berlin jetzt ist
handlungsdruck irgendetwas zu tun
deshalb ist zurück zwölf auch stärker in
den mittelpunkt als das bisher der fall
gewesen ist was eine lehrstelle ist die
ich nicht erklären kann die ich aber
finde ist das argument wir möchten uns
immer noch vorbehalten weitere
eskalationsschritte gehen zu können
sollte es noch schlimmer kommen die
frage wäre was soll da noch schlimmer
aus passieren in der ukraine also eine
öffentliche hinrichtung von präsident
zine el- ski oder so sagen was wäre das
schlimmste eigentlich ist das escalation
szenario wie wir es uns vorgestellt
haben doch genau eingetreten und hierzu
wäre doch der zeitpunkt wirklich süßer
zu sanktionieren er kam ich möchte gerne
an dieser stelle mit ihnen nochmal über
mögliche motive des russischen
präsidenten sprechen wir wissen hat in
seiner tv-ansprache ja die
kriegserklärung quasi publik gemacht und
hat auch unter anderem über die
entnazifizierung der ukraine gesprochen
die nötig sei wie genau haben wir das zu
verstehen also das ist ein bestimmter
der mythos ist de facto außer bestimmtes
bild was sie in der russischen im
russischen diskurs seit jahren befindet
letztlich hat das damit zu tun dass die
gesamte ukrainische regierung oder
ukrainische regierung auch in der
vergangenheit als illegitim betrachtet
werden und da wird diese metapher dass
das der nazis verwendet im kontext damit
mit den vorwürfen dass sie gegen die uhr
gehen die russischsprachigen minderheit
im donbass vorgehen würde also sagen
völkermord genozid nazis ist hier ein
kontext und die rede war sozusagen hatte
zwei zielrichtungen erste sie auf eine
veränderung des genozids in don was also
eine regional begrenzte perspektive aber
durch den passus den sie gerade
angesprochen arbeitet sich die
perspektive
entnazifizierung und entmilitarisierung
der gesamten ukraine
spätestens da wurde eigentlich seien die
gesamte stoßrichtung klar und das ist ja
auch die grundlage für die wie ich finde
völlig berechtigte vermutung heute
morgen dass er auf einen
regierungswechsel in der ukraine abzielt
es gibt unzählige solidaritätsbekundung
vom westen und eben harte sanktionen
beschlossen worden sind us präsident
biden hat das gestern abend erklärt wir
haben die kommissionspräsidenten eben
noch gehört all das wird russland
isolieren international kann russland
sich auf china verlassen wenn es dann
doch rohstoffe braucht wenn es gelder
braucht ich glaube was rüstungs produkte
betrifft was rohstoffe betrifft ja das
ist eine allianz in werden nicht auf
direkte militärischen beistands leistung
aber diese stehen ja auch im moment gar
nicht zur debatte aber ich glaube das
wichtigste ist das jenaer rückendeckung
gibt im politischen sinne das lässt sich
die ortungs vorstellung die
ostern im moment propagiert für den
euroatlantischen raum aber auch im
globalen maßstab von china trotz des
unbehagens jetzt in der ukraine krise
letztlich geteilt werden es gibt
vielleicht eine kleinere differenz jetzt
in dem konkreten vorgehen und der art
des vorgehens in der ukraine das scheint
von der chinesischen führung nicht
sondern nicht gut hier zu werden aber
wenn man das ganz große bild betrifft
beißt die maus keinen faden ab da sehen
wir zwei
kooperationspartner die eine anti
westliche stoßrichtung haben
markus k ein bisschen erstmal vielen
dank und später geht es dann weiter in
die analyse
dann wollen wir jetzt den blick richten
zu einem land das früher sehr enge
verbindungen zu russland gepflegt hat
nämlich frankreich und das diplomatisch
hoffnung hegte da vielleicht noch etwas
erreichen zu können aber man muss sagen
am ende hat das leider nicht geklappt
und damit schalten wir zu unserem
korrespondenten aus paris und zwar zu
thomas walde ja wir sind denn die
reaktionen dort auf die aktuellen
ereignisse
also in diesen minuten kommen hier in
paris zusammen die finanzminister der
europäischen union die französische
regierung hatte dazu eingeladen
ursprünglich zu einem anderen thema aber
dieses treffen steht jetzt ganz im
zeichen dieser aktuellen krise die
finanzminister von deutschland und
frankreich christian lindner und bruno
le maire sind vor einigen minuten dort
aufgetreten und beide haben betont
zunächst einmal die solidarität mit der
ukraine
bruno lemaire hat daran erinnert dass
die eu noch einmal 1,2 milliarden
euro an hilfen für die ukraine zur
verfügung stellen werde und beide haben
betont die bedeutung der sanktionen die
bereits beschlossen worden seien diese
sanktionen so sagten bruno lemaire und
christian lindner würden russland die
russische wirtschaft treffen um
entschuldigung und
russische bevölkerung und die russische
wirtschaft müssten leiden für die
fragwürdigen dummen entscheidungen von
wladimir putin bei diesem treffen wird
es nun darum gehen wie die sanktionen
die beschlossen wurden umgesetzt werden
und auch das haben beide betont wie die
europäische wirtschaft vom möglichen
konsequenzen geschützt werden kann die
sanktionen die beschlossen wurden sagten
beide seien sehr stark da raus war
herauszuhören dass weitere sanktionen
hier zunächst einmal nicht beschlossen
werden soll und eine wichtige folge bei
der umsetzung der sanktionen sind ja
auch steigende energiepreise das
beschäftigt ja alle welche rolle wird er
das in frankreich spielen
das wird hier über diesen treffen eine
ganz wichtige rolle spielen beide haben
betont dass man dabei sei die
energiezufuhr zu sichern und auch die
bevölkerung in europa vor steigenden
energiepreisen
zu schützen die lage ist in den
europäischen ländern da durchaus etwas
unterschiedlich werden auch die
abhängigkeit von russischen importen
dort ganz unterschiedlich ist die
nationalen energiemärkte sehen da anders
aus frankreich beispielsweise hat hier
einen preis deckel beschlossen hat
beschlossen die energiepreise
einzufrieren und hat den
energieversorger unter auflagen gemacht
deutschland hat ein anderes hilfspaket
beschlossen und gemeinsam war hier bei
diesem auftritt und das hört man auch
aus dem kreis der eu-finanzminister dass
man die heimische bevölkerung vor diesen
folgen weiter schützen will dafür wird
man auch bereit sein müssen geld in die
hand zu nehmen dieser gipfel dir war
ursprünglich mal einberufen worden um
über den wirtschafts den stabilitäts und
wachstumspakt in europa zu sprechen und
auch mögliche haushalts auflagen wie man
stabilität der haushalte wieder sichern
kann schulden begrenzen kann das ist
alles ein bisschen zurückgedrängt worden
aber das wird durchaus eine rolle
spielen die deutschen werden sicherlich
sagen dass man jetzt versuchen muss
haushalte trotzdem in ordnung zu bringen
um sich
handels spiegel rolle handlungsspielraum
auch weiter zu arbeiten die franzosen
werden sicherlich mehr betonen wie nötig
es ist geld weiter in die hand zu nehmen
die bevölkerung zu schützen frankreich
ist ja damit ganz gut durch die krise
gekommen ist man sehr viel geld in die
hand genommen hat die französische
wirtschaft ist da recht gut durch die
krise gekommen auch das wird hier am
rande sicherlich eine rolle spielen
werden thomas weide war das mit
informationen live aus paris vielen dank
und jetzt live aus berlin das zdf
morgenmagazin
[Musik]
heute im studio variiert von waldenfels
und mitri sirin
guten tag guten morgen am tag zwei der
russischen invasion eine neue brutale
wirklichkeit die wir erfahren müssen
russland greift die ukraine von drei
seiten an vom osten vom norden und von
süden gesehen hier bilder eines
zerstörten panzers über der krim wohl
ein zerstörter ukrainischer panzer also
das soll zumindest über der krim sein
wir können das nicht verifizieren es
gibt dutzende solcher filme die gerade
im internet kursieren ja also der
angriff auf tier heißt es aus der
ukraine der habe sozusagen mehr oder
weniger begonnen wenige kilometer vor
der ukrainischen hauptstadt stehen die
truppen es gibt viel zu besprechen auch
an diesem freitagmorgen sehr viele
verschiedene aspekte und damit blicken
wir jetzt auf unseren themen überblick
für die nächste halbe stunde
russische einmarsch explosionen und
feuer auch in der ukrainischen
hauptstadt hier
krisengipfel die eu und deutschland
suchen nach antworten und
sanktionspaket mit welchen maßnahmen
russland jetzt getroffen werden sollten
ja wir berichten auch heute morgen
genauso wie gestern live und viel länger
aus den krisengebieten wir schalten auch
in die europäischen hauptstädte und in
die usa um uns die situation dort
erklären zu lassen haben natürlich aber
auch gesprächsgäste hier bei uns
zugeschaltet pariert hat gesprochen um
kurz nach acht mit nancy faeser der
bundesinnenministerium über die aktuelle
situation
ebenso haben wir das getan jean
asselborn dem luxemburgischen
außenminister so ein bisschen aus
europäischer perspektive natürlich wie
john jersey ist der designierte
generalsekretär der fdp was hält die
partei eigentlich vom vorgehen aktuell
der allianz und gregor gysi der
außenpolitische sprecher der linkspartei
wird ebenfalls unser gesprächsgast seien
später um viertel vor zehn
jetzt schalten wir pünktlich um 9 uhr
zur piraterie colo die hat nämlich
nachrichtenüberblick in der heute
express guten morgen guten morgen
vielen lieben dank einen schönen guten
morgen liebe zuschauerinnen und
zuschauer die ukrainische armee liefert
sich nach angaben des generalstabs
heftige gefechte mit russischen truppen
in der nähe von kiew der ukrainische
aussenminister clever spricht außerdem
von raketenbeschuss in der hauptstadt
twitter videos sollen einschläge zeigen
wohnhäuser stehen in flammen
zahlreiche einwohner der stadt haben die
nacht in u-bahnhöfen verbracht nach
angaben von präsident alan ski sind
bislang 137 ukraine getötet und mehr als
300 verletzt worden angaben über tote
auf russischer seite gibt es bisher
nicht im laufe des tages rechnet die
ukrainische regierung mit
panzerangriffen auf kiew ein berater des
innenministers schrieb auf telegram die
verteidiger stünden mit abwehrraketen
bereit präsident salih hat bereits eine
komplette generalmobilmachung angeordnet
männliche staatsbürger im alter von 18
bis 60 dürfen demnach das land nicht
mehr verlassen
us-außenminister blinken geht davon aus
dass russlands präsident putin die
ukrainische regierung stürzen will am
abend kündigte us präsident biden an
7000 weitere soldaten nach europa zu
verlegen die zunächst in deutschland
stationiert werden sollen diese würden
aber nicht in der ukraine kämpfen
sondern die nato-verbündeten verteidigen
immer mehr länder weltweit verhängen
sanktionen gegen russland in der eu
haben sich die staats und
regierungschefs am abend auf
strafmaßnahmen in den bereichen energie
finanzen und transport geeinigt die
finanz sanktionen zielen auf 70 prozent
des russischen bankenmarkt ab das geht
im ukrainischen botschafter in
deutschland wenig nicht weit genug er
wird speziell der bundesregierung kälte
und gleichgültigkeit vor jede bitte um
militärische unterstützung sei einfach
abgeschmettert worden sagte minic im zdf
er kritisierte auch dass sich gerade
deutschland beim eu-gipfel dagegen
gewandt habe russland aus dem
internationalen zahlungssystem swift
auszuschließen
in russland wurden nach angaben von
bürgerrechtlern mittlerweile mehr als
1700 menschen bei anti kriegs protesten
festgenommen allein in der hauptstadt
moskau sein ist knapp 1000 gewesen trotz
eines demonstrationsverbots und
angedrohten harten strafen gingen in
zahlreichen russischen städten menschen
auf die straße
und jetzt noch die wetteraussichten und
die hat benjamin stufe für uns
donnerwetter das wetter wird ihnen
präsentiert von bett1 de
vielen dank pina und guten morgen liebe
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer herzlich
willkommen zum wetter perspektivisch ist
es der hochdruckeinfluss vom atlantik
der uns ein sehr freundliches sehr
sonniges und trockenes wochenende
beschert es wird auch sehr windstill
werden das ist heute noch nicht der fall
denn verantwortlich für das
wettergeschehen heute sind die
tiefdruckgebiete über skandinavien die
bescheren uns nicht nur april wetter
sondern auch noch mal ordentlich windige
verhältnisse coco gleich darauf zuvor
aber der blick zurück auf die
vergangenen stunden das regen bank hat
zwischen einem und zehn liter regen auf
den quadratmeter gebracht schnee war
auch mit dem spiel heute morgen jetzt
nur noch am alpenrand bei temperaturen
aktuell gemessen zwischen -3 grad in
kaufbeuren bis plus fünf grad auf borkum
starten wir vor allem in einer großen
kurve vom nordosten bis zum schwarzwald
durchaus mit sonnigen momenten in den
tag im südosten zieht der schnee noch ab
von westen allerdings werden die wolken
schon wieder dichter und da zieht das
april wetter an diesem tag ins land
regen schnee graupel das ist das wetter
programm auch das eine oder das andere
gewitter wird sich bilden im umfeld
dieser gewitter dann durchaus stürmische
böen und auch sonst ein ziemlich
lebhafter wind der immer mal für lücken
in dieser wolkendecke sorgt ein bisschen
sonnige momente wird es also geben aber
meistens bleibt es doch dicht und grau
bei tageshöchsttemperaturen heute
zwischen drei grad richtung östlichen
mittelgebirge und am alpenrand bis 10
grad am oberrhein und damit sind wir bei
den hochdruck geprägten aussichten für
die kommenden drei tage morgen
verklingenden schneeschauer im süden und
dann aber sonnig und trocken trocken
nicht nur übers wochenende sondern auch
hinein in die kommende woche milder wird
zum montag tageshöchsttemperaturen dann
zwischen 4 und 12 grad soweit zum wetter
für den moment kommen sie mit diesen
aussichten jetzt gut in den freitag
donnerwetter das wetter wurde ihnen
präsentiert von bett1 de
vielen dank benjamin es ist kurz nach
neun normalerweise hätten wir jetzt
schon die sendung beendet das zdf
morgenmagazin sendet heute länger tag 2
der kriegerischen katastrophe die
russland gestern startete und die die
friedens- und sicherheitsarchitektur in
europa komplett auf den kopf stellt uns
noch lange beschäftigen wird und wie die
politik ausdrücklich gestern noch mal
betont hat auch folgen für uns hier
haben wird wir wollen sie über all das
an diesem morgen ganz umfassend in einer
langen ausgabe dann noch informieren und
haben unter anderem noch diese meldung
bekommen präsident selensky hat am
telefon mit dem österreichischen
bundeskanzler noch mal gesagt er wisse
nicht wie lange sein leben lang ist ein
land noch geben werde und wie lange er
selbst noch am leben sei also
dramatische nachrichten zehntausende
ukraine machten sich gerade auf in den
westen fliehen richtung polen das haben
uns unsere komponenten heute morgen
schon erzählt laut ukrainische regierung
diese meldung ist ungefähr 23 stunden
alt gibt es 137 todesopfer ich glaube
nicht mehr dass diese zahl leider muss
man das sagen aktuell ist man hört von
massiven explosionen in der hauptstadt
hiervon raketenbeschuss wir blicken
gleich wieder live zu unseren
korrespondentinnen und korrespondenten
hier sehen sie noch mal bilder der
zivilbevölkerung die dort schutz sucht
vermutlich in luftschutzbunkern in
metrostationen die dazu ausgebaut wurden
also eine wirklich brisante situation
und die aktuelle lage fassen jetzt an
der streicher und dank freier zusammen
zerstörung rauch und feuer in einem
wohngebiet mittlerweile rücken russische
truppen auch ins gebiet um kiel vor die
nacht und der frühe morgen in der
ukrainischen hauptstadt wurden von
lauten explosionen zerrissen
raketenbeschuss aus kiew die ukrainische
armee gibt an zwei davon im flug
zerstört zu haben veröffentlichte ein
amateurvideo ein wohnhaus geht in
flammen auf immer wieder sirenen die
ukrainische zivilbevölkerung nach der
ersten kriegs nacht schrecken und
todesangst versetzt tausende haben
schutz gesucht in u bahnhöfen
wir waren nicht darauf vorbereitet zu
fliehen niemand hatte mit dem
kriegsbeginn gerechnet und dass sie
direkt kiew angreifen würden
man wusste in der panik gar nicht wohin
und wie man sich verhalten sollte die
menschen unter schock viele versuchen zu
fliehen dass der andrang an den grenzen
zu den europäischen nachbarstaaten
bisher nicht noch größer war mag daran
liegen dass es vielerorts schwer war
voranzukommen seit dem gestrigen morgen
rollt die russische militär offensive
von mehreren flanken diese rakete schlug
in einem wohngebiet von kiew ein was
haben die ukrainischen streitkräfte dem
entgegenzusetzen
der ukrainische präsident sehr lenski
organisiert nach eigenen worten aus kiew
heraus den widerstand seine worte ein
verzweifelter appell
ich habe 27 staats und regierungschefs
gefragt ob die ukraine in der nato sein
kann ich habe direkt gefragt alle haben
angst keiner antwortet mir
am späten abend hatte er eine allgemeine
mobilmachung angeordnet russland hatte
behauptet nur gegen militäreinrichtungen
vorzugehen doch nach den worten des
ukrainischen präsidenten aus der nacht
werden längst auch zivile ziele
beschossen kolonnen rücken auf die
hauptstadt vor
ich bin hauptsächlich müde und
verängstigt es ist ein ausnahmezustand
nichts davon fühlt sich real an keine
ahnung wie ich das alles einordnen soll
eu-kommissionspräsident in ursula von
der leyen sagt heute früh nach stunden
der beratungen der eu staats und
regierungschefs dass der kreml zur
rechenschaft gezogen werde man habe sich
auf massive sanktionen geeinigt die auf
70 prozent des russischen bankenmarkt
abzielen am nachmittag berät erneut die
nato auf einem krisengipfel über diese
russische offensive wie sie europa seit
langem nicht gesehen hat
zugeschaltet ist uns unsere
korrespondentin katrin eigendorf die in
der ukraine für uns unterwegs sind
kathrin wo genau sind sie jetzt gerade
und was leben sie dort
ich bin in nizza mit meinem team und wir
sind jetzt war 100 kilometer südwestlich
von kiew entfernt auch hier hat es in
der nacht angriffe gegeben auch hier
immer wieder alarm wir haben auch einen
teil der nacht hier im schutz keller
verbringen müssen unseres hotels also
auch hier ist die stimmung sehr
angespannt aber wenn man sich jetzt mal
die gesamtlage im land anguckt dann
verschärft sich die lage vor allem in
kiew in der hauptstadt es ist so dass
bodentruppen auf die stadt vordringen
wir haben vorhin bilder im ukrainischen
fernsehen gesehen das ist in einigen
teilen der stadt auch mittlerweile zu
häuserkämpfen wohl kommt das ist die
situation aktuell aus regierungskreisen
hören wir dass angeblich russische
soldaten fahrzeuge der ukrainischen
nationalgarde gekapert haben sollen und
damit in der stadt unterwegs sind das
begründet natürlich warum präsident
seelen ski sehr besorgt um seine eigene
sicherheit ist denn das erklärte ziel
der russen ist ja die regierung in kiew
zu entmachten
also ist der präsident das erste ziel
und diese sagen wir mal undercover
agenten die jetzt in der stadt unterwegs
sind sind eine große bedrohung was
bedeutet das alles für die menschen im
land für die bürgerinnen und bürger wir
haben ja schon verschiedene bilder
gesehen wie die menschen versuchen aus
den städten zu fliehen und sich in
sicherheit zu bringen
ja es machen sich viele menschen auf die
flucht aber natürlich ist das eine
kleine minderheit die schafft das land
zu verlassen
viele sind einfach verzweifelt wissen
gar nicht wo sie jetzt hin sollen denn
es ist ja klar hier sind längst nicht
mehr nur strategische ziele im fokus der
russen die russische armee hat so hören
wir den weg frei gemacht auch auf die
stadt mario pohl im osten der ukraine
das ist eines der wichtigsten
industriezentren wenn es darum geht
strategische zentren einzunehmen wenn es
darum geht die hauptstadt einzunehmen
dann wird das enorm viele auch zivile
opfer kosten und das besorgt natürlich
die bevölkerung hier sehr
ich sehe aber auch in meinen gesprächen
eine große entschlossenheit also sehr
viele männer melden sich freiwillig
dafür hier gegen die russische armee zu
kämpfen
ich denke das wird für putin nicht
einfach hier die kontrolle über kiew und
auch andere bereiche zu bekommen also
die muster einfach mit sehr starkem
widerstand ein großer entschlossenheit
der ukrainischen bevölkerung rechnen die
stimmung ist hier wirklich so
[Musik]
das ist um die zukunft des landes geht
katrin eigendorf war das bleiben sie
weiter bitte gut vorsichtig wir bedanken
uns für diese berichterstattung für den
augenblick danke
ja es gibt mehrere berichte wonach
russische truppen immer weiter in die
stadtkirche eindringen also das wird
sich jetzt immer dramatisch zuspitzen
vermutlich wir gehen jetzt erst mal nach
moskau zu unserer kollegin anna heißt es
ist natürlich diese krise auch einen in
der nachrichten krieg jeder verbreitet
seine eigene wirklichkeit was verbreitet
moskau
ja es ist hier jetzt sehr spannend denn
in den russischen agenturen findet man
so gut wie gar keine meldungen zu kiew
dafür gibt es jede menge meldungen über
den osten der ukraine über den don bass
dort seien neue städte eingenommen
wurden dort hätten
separatisten wieder eroberungen
gestartete gleichzeitig wird über die
agenturen verbreitet dass es jede menge
angriffe vonseiten des ukrainischen
militärs gegeben habe in den letzten
tagen und letzten stunden sechs zivile
opfer zwei tote lehrer erst heute morgen
als eine schule mit einem wurfgeschoss
im separatisten gebiet von seiten des
ukrainischen militärs beschossen worden
sei und das dient natürlich ein narrativ
dem narrativ das op team mit seinen
russischen streitkräfte neben nun sich
aufgeschwungen hat um den osten der
ukraine zu befreien gewissermaßen und
diesen völkermord der da angeblich
stattfinden soll zu beenden gleichzeitig
wird es heute möglicherweise auch darum
gehen so wurde es zumindest gestern
abend angekündigt der nördliche krim
kanal wurde gestern abend angeblich von
russischen truppen eingenommen nun geht
es um die eroberung der städte herten
und emily youtube all diese beiden
städte könnten eine landverbindung
zwischen grimm und donbass im osten der
ukraine schaffen das ist das was wir
heute noch erwartet werden könnte anna
diese mehr die da von putin ausgeht vom
genozid der angeblich begangen wird an
der russisch stämmigen bevölkerung in
der ukraine diese mär von der
entnazifizierung die glaubt ja längst
nicht jeder in russland vor allen dingen
die jüngeren haben sie uns ja heute
morgen schon mehrfach gesagt da gab es
ja proteste gestern abend wie geht man
damit um in russland
genau gestern abend gab es um 19 uhr
ortszeit hier anti kriegs proteste
dort hat uns eine jüngere teilnehmerin
sehr eindrücklich folgendes geschildert
ich zitiere
das kann man sich nicht ruhig ansehen
wir sagen natürlich meine eltern gehen
nicht dorthin deine gesundheit ist
wertvoller aber wissen sie ein krieg das
ist zu viel für mich und es gab wir
hatten gestern auch eine straßenumfrage
gestartet die es natürlich nicht
repräsentativ aber dort zeichnete sich
eben das bild ab dass insbesondere die
jüngeren sehr skeptisch dem krieg
gegenüber eingestellt sind während die
älteren also die mit serviette erfahrung
dann durchaus dem narrativ von putin
folgen und eben sagen naja die ukraine
die gehört doch zu russland und russland
wolle sich jetzt nur das zurück was was
ihm sozusagen zustehe anna vielen dank
für dieses schiff wird diese schilderung
live aus moskau wir wollen jetzt
weitermachen mit dem mächtigsten
westlichen bündnispartner wir wollen uns
nämlich anhören wie die reaktionen auf
all dies aus washington aussehen und mit
welchen kriegsziele putins die usa
rechnen und haben dazu gesprochen mit
unserer korrespondentin claudia bertz
und sie hat folgendes gesagt
[Musik]
die us-regierung geht auch davon aus
dass es russland in erster linie darum
geht die regierung in kiew eben zu
stürzen aussenminister blinken hat dazu
noch mal gesagt dass es dabei durchaus
auch zu einer belagerung der stadt kiew
kommen könnte und aus dem pentagon hören
wir ich zitiere das mal dort sagte ein
vertreter wir gehen davon aus dass die
russischen streitkräfte die absicht
haben die regierung zu entmachten und
ihre eigene regierungsform zu
installieren was diese ersten schritte
in richtung kiew erklären würde das
heißt das ist die die der erklärung
dafür ganz klar
als schnelles ziel um die regierung eben
zu entmachten
ja soweit die reaktionen aus dem ausland
genauer aus washington und auch in
deutschland gab es am abend ja nach
einer ansprache des bundeskanzlers putin
wird nicht gewinnen das war wohl die
deutlichste botschaft ja auch hier ist
man entschieden harte sanktionen gegen
russland volle solidarität mit der
ukraine und die gesamten reaktionen die
fast jetzt ihren fritsche für uns
zusammen
für die demonstranten gestern vor dem
kanzleramt ist klar was zu tun ist putin
stoppen mit maximalen sanktionen gegen
russland und waffenlieferungen an die
ukraine
eine ukrainische flagge auch im
kanzleramt doch viel mehr als
solidarität will der hausherr dem land
nicht zu sagen betont stattdessen in
einer fernsehansprache der krieg dürfe
sich nicht weiter ausdehnen
putin sollte die entschlossenheit der
nato nicht unterschätzen alle ihre
mitglieder zu verteidigen das gilt
ausdrücklich für unsere nato partner im
baltikum in polen und in rumänien in
bulgarien und in der slowakei ohne wenn
und aber
außenministerin bernburg wirft putin im
zdf-interview wahnvorstellungen vor sie
und kanzler stolz sein von ihm angelogen
worden daneben fordert die grüne
außenministerin eine bessere ausstattung
fürs militär
wir erleben aber wenn jetzt die
bundeswehr anschauen zum beispiel dass
er mit blick auf material natürlich
deutlich deutlich mehr machen müssen
deutlich mehr machen das sieht beim
thema verteidigung auch der
bundesfinanzminister so in der
vergangenheit sei die truppe
vernachlässigt worden
es gab eine friedensdividende das heißt
wir hatten nach dem ende des kalten
krieges das gefühl das brauchen wir
nicht mehr andere übernehmen die lasten
etwa die vereinigten staaten die union
hat sich an tag eins des krieges hinter
den kurs der ampel regierung gestellt
nur beim thema waffenlieferungen gibt es
bei manch einem einen sinneswandel
es ist jetzt richtig weil nicht mehr
gesprochen wird dass auch deutschland
die ukraine durch lieferung von
militärischer ausrüstung unterstützt in
der deutschen politik hat ein umdenken
begonnen beim umgang mit autoritären
staaten doch für die ukraine dürfte das
zu spät kommen
ja und ein umdenken bei manchen
politikern zumindest auch in der frage
nach waffenlieferungen von
defensivwaffen da werden ja der 1 da
werden ja einige rufe tatsächlich lauter
aber offiziell bleibt die
bundesregierung bislang natürlich bei
ihrem strikten nein wir wollen weiter in
die analyse gehen und zwar mit unserem
hauptstadtkorrespondenten mit thomas
reichert der uns jetzt zugeschaltet ist
thomas kanzler scholz hat gesagt putin
wird nicht gewinnen zeigte sich vor
allem entschlossen alle nato-mitglieder
zu verteidigen also ohne wenn und aber
sollte der angriff denn über die ukraine
hinaus gehen also setzt man doch auf
militärische abschreckung oder wie
verhält man sich ja es war auf jeden
fall ein wichtiges signal an die
osteuropäischen staaten dass deutschland
zu der nato verpflichtung steht zu
artikel 5 dass ein angriff auf ein land
eines auf alle bedeuten würde aber es
bedeutet natürlich für deutschland mehr
als dass man jetzt sozusagen drei
eurofighter der luftwaffe
zusätzlich nach constanta in rumänien am
schwarzen meer schickt und dort den
luftraum über dem schwarzen meer an der
nato südostflanke zu überwachen das
bedeutet das vermutlich der
oberbefehlshaber der nato streitkräfte
gehört das schon angekündigt weitere
anforderungen die bundeswehr kommen in
einer situation wo offenbare dass die
bundeswehr schlecht vorbereitet ist der
heeresinspekteur hat gestern gesagt er
stehe quasi blank da
und das zeigt sich dass der viel
verpasst wurde in der vergangenheit die
bundeswehr ist ausgerichtet auf
auslandseinsätze jahres 116 afghanistan
oder in mali sie ist nicht mehr darauf
ausgerichtet auf einem großen land krieg
wie man ihn eigentlich geglaubt hatte
der würde der vergangenheit angehören
die mittelfristige finanzplanung für die
bundeswehr die sinkt von 50 milliarden
aktuell auf 47 milliarden im jahr 2025
das soll nun umgesteuert werden die
trendwende sieht man ganz klar in berlin
nicht nur bei der
verteidigungsministerin sondern auch bei
vizekanzler und finanzminister aber das
ist zurückgegangen ein ende einer art
russland leidet die möglicherweise jetzt
reichlich spät kommt nicht nur für
deutschland sondern eben auch für die
verbündeten in osteuropa es sind viele
harte sanktionen auf den weg gebracht
worden von seiten der eu und die wurden
gestern auch noch mal und auch von der
nato der präsident hat das gestern
formuliert die kommissionspräsidentin
hat das am morgen formuliert eine sache
ist nicht formuliert worden nämlich
swift als härteste schwert offenbar will
olaf scholz der kanzler dass jetzt noch
nicht einsetzen aber der grösste
oppositionsführer
cdu-fraktionschef merz sagt das müsste
man jetzt tun dass es davon zu halten
ich glaube dass der innenpolitische
druck und auch von außen welt größer
werden wird und dass der vermutlich noch
bewegung in die sache kommen wird
deutschland vermittelt ja auf diese
weise dass es wieder unentschieden sei
olaf scholz hat lange dafür gebraucht
sich bei nordstream 2 klar zu
positionieren er hat dann am dienstag
dann schnell entschieden aber nun ist
dran und ertrag sich warum zögert
deutschland da wieder ich fand
interessant was der luxemburgische
außenminister heute früh bei uns im
morgenmagazin gesagt hat dass beim eu
außenministertreffen heute nachmittag in
brüssel trifft weiter auf dem tisch ist
als da kommt sicher glaube ich bewegung
in die sache danke für die
einschätzungen thomas reichert
hauptstadtkorrespondent also da ist also
noch musik drin beim thema swift und wir
haben liebe zuschauerinnen und zuschauer
schon an diesem morgen viele politische
stimmen zur aktuellen krise auch gehört
hier bei uns unter anderem die spd
bundesinnenministerium nancy faeser
nachher noch von den linken gregor gysi
bei uns im gespräch und jetzt hören wir
eine stimme von dem designierten
fdp-generalsekretär bijan djir sarai
guten tag herzlich willkommen
hallo ich grüße sie auf twitter haben
sie geschrieben wir benötigen dringend
eine neue sicherheitsarchitektur
angesichts des russischen vorgehens
aktuell was heißt das konkret
na ja fakt ist ja dass in den letzten
zwei jahren ja sehr intensiv über die
zukunft der nato als organisation
gesprochen wurde ich darf erinnern dass
der französische präsident vor zwei
jahren sogar die nato als hirntot
bezeichnet hat übrigens hat auch
deutschland in den letzten jahren als
nato-mitglied keine gute figur abgegeben
wenn es um die frage ging
wie setzen wir gemeinsam die nato ziele
um das bedeutet mit blick auf die
zukunft dass diese debatte spätestens
jetzt beendet ist jedem ist inzwischen
klar dass hoffe ich davon gehe ich aus
dass die welt in der wir leben sich
dramatisch verändert hat und
dementsprechend muss auch die nato auf
diese herausforderung vorbereitet sein
die letzten stunden die letzten tage
haben mir gezeigt dass ihr die in der
tat in der die nato diese fähigkeiten
besitzt und vor allem die nato in der
lage ist auch handlungsfähig zu sein
wenn es darauf ankommt dann der blick
auf die deutsche bundesregierung was
kann die jetzt tun die rufe nach
waffenlieferungen werden ja lauter wie
stehen sie dazu na ja zunächst einmal
wir zunächst einmal muss ja klar sein
was diese ereignisse für uns als land
bedeuten wir haben in den letzten jahren
das ist auch in ihrem beitrag vorhin
erwähnt worden wir haben in den letzten
jahren es vernachlässigt beispielsweise
in die eigene außen und
sicherheitspolitik vor allem in die
sicherheits und verteidigungspolitik zu
investieren es geht um den zustand der
bundeswehr das ist etwas was so nicht
weitergehen kann von daher ist das jetzt
nicht nur eine debatte sondern das ist
sehr konkret wir werden in den nächsten
jahren oder jetzt damit auch beginnen
die bundeswehr zukunftsfähig zu machen
und vor allem mit blick auf die
europäische entwicklung es wäre gut dass
wir in europa künftig mit einer stimme
sprechen nicht nur in der außenpolitik
sondern auch in der verteidigungspolitik
dass es auch mit blick auf die debatten
die noch kommen werden eine europäische
verteidigungsarmee ist aus meiner sicht
notwendig unter dem in der nato quasi
ein gebettelt aber das ist etwas was
kommen wird sie haben jetzt versäumnisse
angesprochen besonders auch in bezug auf
die bundeswehr und sie haben auch gesagt
schon die naivität gegenüber russland
müsse ein ende haben wer in deutschland
darf sich denn da jetzt besonders
angesprochen fühlen
die politik insgesamt bin selbst seit
vielen jahren mitglied des auswärtigen
ausschusses
und ines es in der tat so dass in
deutschland lange die vorstellung
existiert hat das
länder oder starten oder regime wie ich
in china in russland oder im iran im
grunde genommen mit der zeit durch
wirtschaftliche entwicklung sich
demokratisieren werden und auch
zuverlässige gesprächspartner auf der
internationalen bühne sein werden also
diese das was man früher gesagt hat
wandel durch handel
ich glaube dass das dass sich das als
falsch dargestellt hat übrigens nicht
erst seit gestern aus meiner sicht schon
länger und jetzt muss eines klar sein
natürlich ist die diplomatie weiterhin
alternativlos aber die diplomatie muss
auch glaubwürdig sein und damit die
glaubwürdigkeit funktioniert muss man
gerade gegenüber staaten wie russland
oder auch china oder iran klar machen
dass wir auch in der lage sind dass wir
auch über
sicherheitsarchitekturen über die
fähigkeiten in der sicherheitspolitik
verfügen und das gehört mit zum punkt
der glaubwürdigkeit bijan djir sarai war
dass der designierte fdp generalsekretär
vielen dank für dieses gespräch sehr
gerne
dieser angriff russlands auf die ukraine
hat auch die finanzmärkte die
internationalen finanzmärkte schwer
erschüttert und darum blicken wir jetzt
nach frankfurt zur börse und dort steht
für uns die nahm eine zehner gestern
sind die börsen ja wirklich hier rund um
den globus auf talfahrt gegangen wie
sieht denn der start in den tag heute
aus es ist jetzt so liegen als sie
gleich also minimal entspannter nenne
ich es mal dennoch müssen wir uns in
nächster zeit auf schwankenden börsen
einstellen in asien und den usa haben
sich die kurse nach heftigen
kurseinbrüchen gestern weitestgehend
wieder gefangen und auch der dax ist
etwas erholt in den tag gestartet
aktuell 0,2 prozent knapp im plus bei
14.000 und 78 punkten heute vormittag
bleibt der handel der russischen börse
nach heftigen kurseinbrüchen gestern
geschlossen von entwarnung kann auch
hier noch keine rede sein vor allem eben
auch weil dieser krieg das vertrauen der
anleger erschüttert so wie uns alle und
welche auswirkungen tatsächlich diese
sanktionen gegen russland für die
deutsche wirtschaft haben ist noch
völlig offen nun hat die politik gestern
auch die bürgerinnen und bürger hier
eingeschworen darauf dass man
wahrscheinlich
auch die folgen tragen müsste für ein
beherztes handeln der politik bedeutet
auch dass beispielsweise die
energiepreise steigen aber das wird sich
auch wiederum auf die inflation aus also
hoffen müssen wir uns da künftig
einstellen auf beides auf inflation und
eben diese weiter steigenden preise denn
erst vorgestern hat die bundesregierung
ja ein paket geschnürt welches
einkommensschwächeren haushalten bei den
energiekosten unter die arme greifen
soll und da war der einmarsch der
truppen in die ukraine noch geschichte
also da war es noch gar nicht da gerade
nun sprechen wir über die öl und
gaspreise nun kommt heute morgen eine
umfrage des münchner ifo instituts
wonach so viele unternehmen wie noch nie
in den nächsten drei monaten ihre preise
erhöhen wollen besonders viele firmen im
einzelhandel wollen ihre preise anheben
darunter vor allem die
lebensmittelhändler gefolgt vom
großhandel danach die industrie und das
baugewerbe
auch bei den großen wirtschafts
konzernen ist die angst vor steigenden
energiepreisen inzwischen deutlich
angekommen so zahlte die basf allein im
vierten quartal vergangenen jahres 800
millionen euro mehr für energie es
scheint als sei die hohe inflationsrate
tatsächlich gekommen um zu bleiben eine
fünf vor dem komma der inflationsrate im
gesamten jahr 2022 wird gerade
wahrscheinlicher als eine 3 hört man vom
ifo institut
da setzt die europäische zentralbank
wiederum unter druck es könnte sein dass
sie bei ihrer nächsten ratssitzung am 10
märz maßnahmen andeutet um aus dieser
ultra lockeren geldpolitik auszusteigen
im kampf gegen immer weiter steigende
preise
und es klingt nun natürlich sehr zynisch
aber gestern sagte mir ein börsenhändler
er hoffe nicht dass wir uns beim
nächsten weihnachtsfest die frage
stellen müssen schenken wir uns eheringe
oder vielleicht doch lieber
tankgutscheine also die börse hat sich
nach internationalen turbulenzen heute
wieder ein wenig berappelt aber es
bleibt die unsicherheit sagt sina
mainitz vielen dank nach frankfurt gerne
und jetzt live aus berlin das zdf
morgenmagazin
[Musik]
heute im studio variiert von waldenfels
und mitri sirin ganz herzlich willkommen
liebe zuschauerinnen und zuschauer und
wir wollen diese halbe stunde mit
aktuellen bildern beginnen die uns aus
der ukraine erreichen die wir ihnen
gerne zeigen wollen und zwar sehen wir
dort unter anderem bilder von zerstörten
panzern der ukrainischen armee in person
das ist eine seehafenstadt im süden der
ukraine nördlich der halbinsel krim
aber wir sehen auch diese bilder das
sind schutzsuchende die in
metrostationen bus alte station oder
luftschutzbunkern zuflucht suchen sich
ausruhen und absolut nicht wissen wie es
weiter geht aber es gibt auch menschen
die sich mut machen und zwar sind dass
diese bilder aus der ukraine aus einer
metrostation gleich müssten sie kommen
und die können wir uns jetzt auch
anschauen wir sehen dort menschen die
sich mit zu singen
[Musik]
die irgendwie versuchen angesichts
dieser dramatischen und beängstigenden
lage dennoch ihren mut und ihren
optimismus zu behalten wir haben gleich
noch ein gespräch mit dem
außenpolitischen sprecher der linken mit
gregor gysi haben noch diverse gespräche
auch mit unseren korrespondenten in
russland in der ukraine und anderswo
wollen jetzt aber weitermachen mit den
nachrichten und geben rüber zu wenn das
denn so stimmt ja natürlich peanut an
ricos damit heute express guten
morgen guten morgen und auch ihnen liebe
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer guten
morgen die ukrainische armee liefert
sich nach angaben des generalstabs
heftige gefechte mit russischen truppen
ersten angaben zufolge sollen sie kiew
erreicht haben der ukrainische
aussenminister cool aber spricht
außerdem von raketenbeschuss in der
hauptstadt twitter videos aus der nacht
sollen einschläge zeigen wohnhäuser
stehen in flammen am morgen wird die
zerstörung sichtbar mehrere gebäude sind
stark beschädigt nach angaben von
präsident seelands die sind bislang 137
ukraine getötet und mehr als 300
verletzt worden
im laufe des tages rechnet die
ukrainische regierung mit
panzerangriffen auf kiew ein berater des
innenministers schrieb auf telegramm die
verteidiger stünden mit abwehrraketen
bereit präsident seelands die hat
bereits eine komplette
generalmobilmachung angeordnet männliche
staatsbürger im alter von 18 bis 60
dürfen demnach das land nicht mehr
verlassen
us-außenminister blinken geht davon aus
dass russlands präsident putin die
ukrainische regierung stürzen will am
abend kündigte us-präsident beiden an
7000 weitere soldaten nach europa zu
verlegen die zunächst in deutschland
stationiert werden sollen diese würden
aber nicht in der ukraine kämpfen
sondern die nato-verbündeten verteidigen
immer mehr länder weltweit verhängen
sanktionen gegen russland in der eu
sich die staats und regierungschefs am
abend auf strafmaßnahmen in den
bereichen energie finanzen und transport
geeinigt die finanz sanktionen zielen
auf 70 prozent des russischen
bankenmarkt ab in russland wurden nach
angaben von bürgerrechtlern mittlerweile
mehr als 1700 menschen bei anti kriegs
protesten festgenommen allein in der
hauptstadt moskau seien es knapp 1000
gewesen trotz eines
demonstrationsverbots und angedrohten
taten strafen gingen den zahlreichen
russischen städten menschen auf die
straße
noch nie gab es in deutschland so wenige
verkehrstote wie im vergangenen jahr
laut statistischem bundesamt sind
2569 menschen bei unfällen ums leben
gekommen sechs prozent weniger als im
vorjahr hauptgrund ist demnach das
geringere verkehrsaufkommen infolge der
korona pandemie
und die wetteraussichten hat benjamin
stufe für uns
donnerwetter das wetter wird ihnen
präsentiert von bett1 de
vielen dank pina und guten morgen liebe
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer herzlich
willkommen zum wetter fünf bis zehn grad
das sind die tageshöchsttemperaturen in
mitteleuropa zu mild für die jahreszeit
und es wird zum beginn der kommenden
woche noch milder werden allerdings
nachts könnten wir immer noch in den
frostbereich abrutschen woher kommt
dieses freundliche wetter das
hochdruckgebiet vom atlantik das strebt
in unsere richtung und wird ab morgen
für trockene und sonnige verhältnisse
sorgen aber bis dahin wirken noch die
tiefdruckgebiete des nordens ein über
skandinavien sitzt dieses duo und
schickt zu uns und wolken regen und
richtiges aprilwetter in den vergangenen
12 stunden sah das so aus das regenband
ist einmal durch ein bis zehn liter auf
den quadratmeter gab es in der spitze
schnee war auch mit im spiel der
verklingt jetzt gerade am alpenrand es
startet relativ konnten aber von
nordwesten kommt schon wieder neuer
regen ins land kommen wir gleich drauf
zuvor der blick auf die aktuell
gemessenen temperaturen neuhaus am
rennweg meldet heute morgen minus drei
grad 6 grad sind es auflöst und hier ist
der vormittag im überblick sonnige
momente gibt es zwischen ostseeküste und
schwarzwald allerdings von nordwesten
jetzt schon herein ziehen die schauer
und auch gewitter das wird zum
nachmittag noch intensiver werden regen
schnee graupel und im umfeld der
gewitter durchaus auch stürmische böen
überhaupt heute ein ziemlich lebhafter
wind noch mal das wird morgen abflauen
heute löst es ab und an lücken in den
wolken aus da lässt sich dann die sonne
blicken meistens wird aber eher grau
bleiben bei tageshöchsttemperaturen
heute zwischen drei grad richtung
östlichen mittelgebirge und am alpenrand
zehn grad gibt es richtung oberrhein und
damit sind wir beim blick auf die
aussichten für die hochdruck geprägten
kommenden drei tage morgen verklingen
die schneeschauer im südosten und dann
wird es von tag zu tag immer trockener
sonnige und milde am montag höchstwerte
zwischen 4 und 12 grad soweit zum wetter
für den moment kommen sie mit diesen
aussichten jetzt gut in den freitag
donnerwetter das wetter wurde ihnen
präsentiert von bett1 de
vielen dank benjamin für die
wetteraussichten und ihnen liebe
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer ein
herzliches willkommen zu einer
sondersendung des morgenmagazins hier im
zdf aus aktuellem anlass wir senden
jetzt noch eine stunde und berichten
ausführlich natürlich über tag zwei des
krieges in der ukraine es ist putins
krieg sagen übereinstimmend der
us-präsident und auch bundeskanzler
scholz präsident putin hat die
friedensordnung die
sicherheitsarchitektur in europa
verändert und fährt fort mit seinen
angriffen auf die ukraine sie meldet
zahlreiche angriff auf viele orte mit
flugzeugen artillerie marschflugkörper
und besonders besorgniserregend der
marsch auf kiew der läuft auch auf
vollen touren es fehlen den russischen
truppen nur noch wenige kilometer
luftalarm über der hauptstadt und auch
sogar noch im westlichen lemberg und
darum wollen wir jetzt gehen zu unserer
korrespondentin zu katrin eigendorf die
sich glaube ich 200 kilometer
südwestlich von kiew befindet und auch
dort ist die situation brenzlig hier hat
uns heute morgen schon von luftalarm
berichtet wie ist es gerade kathrin
ja wir sind hier in wie nizza es hat
heute morgen und auch in der nacht
mehrfach alarm gegeben auch wir mussten
die nacht teilweise hier im schutz
keller des hotels verbringen aber wenn
man sich die lage im gesamten land an
ansieht dann ist sicherlich die
zuspitzung im moment rund um die
hauptstadt kiew es ist so dass die
russen mit panzern vordringen aber was
noch viel bedenklicher ist anscheinend
haben russische soldaten fahrzeuge von
nationalgardisten erbeutet und sind
damit in der stadt unterwegs es gibt
also so berichtet es die ukrainische
regierung einige russische oder viele
russische undercover agenten und das ist
besonders bedrohlich weil der präsident
ein ziel von diesen undercover-agenten
sein könnte damit rechnet die regierung
denn ziel putins ist es ja die regierung
in kiew zu entmachten und im prinzip
eine russland treue marionettenregierung
hier zu installieren eine weitere
weitere sehr bedenkliche entwicklung ist
dass die russen nachdem sie vor allem
strategische ziele ja gestern
bombardiert haben sich mittlerweile in
kiew häuserkämpfe liefern wir hören von
ukrainischer seite dass sie wohl auch in
häuser eindringen sich dort in wohnungen
breit machen um
schüssel dort abzugeben
anscheinend ist es den russen auch
gelungen sich den weg nach mario pohl in
eine der wichtigsten hafenstädte der
ukraine und industriemetropole
freizumachen und was die leute jetzt
besonders
besorgt ist natürlich dass immer mehr
zivilisten hier auch opfer der angriffe
werden denn es geht den russen ja darum
kontrolle über die städte zu gewinnen
und das können sie letztendlich
natürlich nur erreichen wenn sie da mit
bodentruppen und soldaten reingehen und
wir müssen einfach damit rechnen dass
die ukraine hier widerstand leisten dass
es zu schweren kämpfen in vielen städten
der ukraine kommen kann es ist
offenkundig eine dramatisch eine bittere
situation für die ukraine was können sie
uns über die fluchtbewegungen sagen
fliehen die zivilisten in der mehrheit
oder bleiben sie im land um ihr land zu
verteidigen
also das ist natürlich schwer darüber
jetzt einen überblick zu bekommen aber
ich würde sagen es ist keine mehrheit
die hier die flucht ergreift sind
menschen auf der flucht ist sitzen viele
menschen auf gepackten koffern aber
erstens mal ist flucht nicht so einfach
die straßen sind hier teilweise
verstopft die wege ja auch nicht einfach
zurück zu legen männer zwischen 18 und
60 18 und 60 können das land sowieso
nicht mehr verlassen weil sie für die
armee bereitstehen müssen also man kann
jetzt nicht davon sprechen dass hier die
mehrheit das land verlässt aber
sicherlich muss europa sich jetzt auf
massive flucht bewegungen aus der
ukraine einrichten aber in der
gesamtlage wie sie sich darstellt ist
die ukrainische bevölkerung schon bereit
hier zu bleiben und ihr land zu
verteidigen das haben wir auch in den
letzten jahren in den letzten acht
jahren dieses krieges erlebt wie
widerstandsfähig diese bevölkerung ist
und wie hartnäckig entschlossen ja im
prinzip für irland einzutreten und was
hier die stimmung ist dass es im prinzip
es geht jetzt hier um die zukunft der
ukraine
vielen dank für diese schilderungen das
war für uns live aus der ukraine katrin
eigendorf finden
und liebe zuschauerinnen und zuschauer
in brüssel war tief in brüssel
verabschiedeten jahres staats und
regierungschefs harte sanktionen es sind
harte aber nicht die härtesten nicht die
härtesten warum ist da noch nicht zum
äußersten kam und was sanktionen mit uns
zu tun haben das erfahren wir jetzt von
natalie wollmann
gestern abend das gebäude der
eu-kommission erleuchtet in den farben
der ukraine auch im innern stehen die eu
staats und regierungschefs an der seite
kiews einigten sich wohl schneller denn
je dass sanktionspaket russland
schmerzlich treffen doch die stärkste
waffe kommt nicht zum einsatz der
ausschluss russlands aus dem
internationalen zahlungsverkehrssystem
swift damit würde der zahlungsverkehr
gestoppt mit gravierenden folgen
und wenn das jetzt abrupt unterbrochen
würde dann würde das auch hierzulande
zu produktionseinbußen führen das wäre
ein schmerzhaft auch für die westlichen
ökonomien wie hoch die gegenseitige
abhängigkeit ist zeigt sich allein schon
beim gas deutsche haushalte zahlen
aktuell 32 prozent mehr als vor einem
jahr der grund russland hat die
lieferung seit monaten gedrosselt gas
ist damit knapp geworden denn immerhin
kommen 55 prozent des erdgases
hierzulande aus russland nun werden die
engpässe wohl weiter zunehmen eine
schlechte nachricht für die verbraucher
das heißt die vorstellung dass wir jetzt
ein plateau erlebt oder erreicht haben
bei den energiepreisen und das damit
allein über die zeit die inflation die
von dieser seite kommt sich wieder
zurückbildet das verschiebt sich weiter
in die zukunft
vermutlich einer der gründe warum
kanzler scholz nicht den ausschluss
russlands aus dem swift system
beschließen wollte statt dessen wille
diesen schritt vorbehalten für später
und einer auf dem er sehr große
hoffnungen lagen der jüngst auch nochmal
gestern abend mit wladimir putin
telefoniert hat war frankreichs
staatspräsident manuel makro der aber
auch nichts erreicht hat und sein
telefonat blieb erfolglos wie kurz und
heftig ne dieses herz und schnell kurz
und schnell ja wir gehen jetzt nach
paris dort gibt es ja das
finanzministertreffen thomas walde steht
für uns bereit also die
eu-finanzminister haben sich beraten
ursprünglich sollte es um den
stabilitäts und wachstumspakt der eu
gehen jetzt gibt es da eine neue lage
welche rolle spielt der russische
überfall auf die ukraine dort
ja der bestimmt jetzt hier die
tagesordnung der finanzminister der
europäischen union bruno lemaire der
französische finanzminister christian
lindner der deutsche haben sich zu
beginn des treffens geäußert haben ihre
solidarität mit der ukraine noch einmal
betont bei diesem treffen heute wird es
darum gehen wie die bereits
beschlossenen sanktionen der technisch
umgesetzt werden sollen und auch darum
wie man die europäische wirtschaft vor
den folgen
möglicherweise es schützen kann die
beiden haben betont noch einmal die
besonders schwere der bereits
beschlossenen sagen johnen bruno le
maire sagte die russische wirtschaft
werde damit empfindlich getroffen die
russische bevölkerung und die russische
wirtschaft müssten nun einen hohen preis
bezahlen für die aggression wladimir
putins wenn man dann allerdings ein
bisschen genauer hingehört hat bei den
baden christian lindner sagte weitere
sanktionen seien nicht ausgeschlossen
dann merkte man da aber doch das
zumindest heute weitere sanktionen nicht
zu erwarten sind und das zahlungssystem
swift das eben angesprochen wurde hätte
ja auch gravierende folgen für die
europäer wenn man die russen dar
ausschließen würde das würde
gaslieferungen dass wir die
rohstofflieferungen erschweren und der
eindruck bleibt auch wenn man sich
hinter den kulissen dort ein bisschen
umhört das von den großen playern von
den großen europäischen mächten derzeit
niemand einen ausschluss russlands aus
diesem zahlungssystem swift forciert
zumindest ist das deck derzeitige stand
okay das sagen also die finanzminister
möglicherweise wird dann bei der
außenminister sitzung das hat heute bei
uns im interview der luxemburgische
außenminister jean asselborn gesagt dass
möglicherweise doch noch auf die
tagesordnung kommt international vielen
dank eines 2 1 für diese einschätzung
aus paris thomas wolter war das
ja wichtig ist eben in einer solchen
welt politisch brisanten lage wie sich
einzelne länder verhalten wer also auf
wessen seite steht in der welt habe ich
heute gelesen der türkische präsident
erdogan da müsse sich entscheiden ob er
zum besten gehört oder nicht die türkei
ist nämlich nato staat aber aktuell in
einer zwickmühle fragen danach bei jörg
brase unserem korrespondenten zuständig
für die türkei ist uns jetzt
zugeschaltet ja wie ambivalent ist denn
das verhältnis der türkei zur ukraine
und auch zu russland
also sagen wir mal so die türkei
unterhält zu beiden ländern ein sehr
enges verhältnis sowohl wirtschaftlich
als eben auch sicherheitspolitisch
präsident erdogan hatte vor kurzem noch
einmal eingeladen zu einem
friedensgipfel an die ukraine und
russland in istanbul wollte man sich
treffen dieser friedensgipfel der ist
jetzt natürlich obsolet geworden durch
den angriff russlands auf die ukraine
die türkei hat dann auch pflichtgemäß
diesen angriff scharf verurteilt fordert
die wiederherstellung der nationalen
souveränität der ukraine ist aber
andererseits muss man wohl sagen
wirtschaftlich durchaus von russland ab
das gilt natürlich vor allem für den
energiesektor durch das schwarze meer
verläuft die pipeline talks kritik
stream mit der die türkei mit russischem
erdgas versorgt wird russland ist der
größte getreide lieferant auch andere
landwirtschaftliche produkte sind
wichtig für die türkei auch der
tourismus ist extrem wichtig für das
land und auch im sicherheitsbereich
arbeitet man eng zusammen die türkei
hatte ja das russische luftabwehrsystem
s400 gekauft das hatte zu großen
protesten in der nato geführt aber
andererseits liegt man in bestimmten
krisengebieten mit russland über kreuz
zum beispiel in syrien unterstützt
russland den der syrischen präsidenten
assad die türkei unterstützte
oppositionelle milizen trotzdem arbeitet
man auch da zusammen 100 positionen
eingerichtet fährt gemeinsame
militärkontrollen das heißt also dass
türkisch russische freiheit das ist ein
durchaus schwieriges ein pragmatisches
aber eben auch ein wichtiges und so
hatte präsident erdogan noch mal gesagt
die türkei könne es sich nicht erlauben
sich sowohl mit der ukraine als auch mit
russland nicht zu verderben dann greifen
wir nochmal einen punkt heraus die
türkei kontrolliert ja den einzigen
seeweg zum schwarzen meer und tier hat
ankara schon gebeten die meerenge für
russische kriegsschiffe zu schließen wie
reagiert ankara darauf
also bisher heißt es aus der türkischen
hauptstadt dass man das prüfe man prüfe
diesen antrag habe jetzt die
rechtsexperten gebeten zu sehen ob es
rechtliche voraussetzungen dafür gibt
die voraussetzung dafür wäre dass ein
kriegsfall vorliegt und zwar im
kriegsfall in denen auch die türkei
verwickelt ist dann könnte sie den
bosporus dicht machen die türkei
kontrolliert in der tat diese einzige
verbindung zwischen dem mittelmeer über
die da das marmarameer und den bosporus
ins schwarze meer ist aber vertraglich
verpflichtet diese durchfahrt offen zu
halten für handelsschiffe aber eben auch
für kriegsschiffe und zwar vor allem für
kriegsschiffe der anrainerstaaten des
schwarzen meeres man will also jetzt
prüfen ob es ob die voraussetzungen
dafür vorliegen den bosporus dicht zu
machen aber militärexperten haben in den
vergangenen tagen glaube ich auch zu
recht festgestellt dass die russische
kriegsmarine natürlich längst alle
kriegsschiffe und u boote die man
braucht um die ukraine von der seeseite
anzugreifen schon längst durch den
bosporus geschleust hat zuletzt war das
der fall anfang februar das heißt also
selbst wenn die türkei sich entschließen
sollte den bus bosporus zu sperren hätte
das glaube ich keinen entscheidenden
einfluss auf den kriegsverlauf in der
ukraine ihre blase war das zur lage der
türkei vielen dank für diese einordnung
wir wollen uns jetzt näher beschäftigen
mit der position der linkspartei in
diesen dramatischen konflikt in diesem
krieg der jetzt auf europäischem boden
stattfindet und er ist uns sehr
zugeschaltet guten morgen herr gysi
guten morgen sie sind außenpolitischer
sprecher der linksfraktion und immer
wieder für eine überraschung gut alles
was ich immer gesagt habe ist an dem tag
gestorben an dem ein
völkerrechtswidriger krieg beginnt das
haben sie gestern in einem podcast
gesagt heißt das jetzt dass sie die
große russische invasion ohne wenn und
aber verurteilen
ohne wenn und aber es ist ein
verbrecherischen angriffskrieg nichts
anderes und das kann man und muss man
verurteilen und zwar schärfsten ihre
partei trotzdem das muss man sagen hatte
immer schon ein offenkundiges russland
problemen also soll heißen nicht
unwesentliche teile ihrer partei haben
immer verständnis für rabiate schritte
von putin geäußert warum kommt jetzt
erst die erkenntnis dass dieser mann
nach völkerrechts maßstäben ein
kriegsverbrecher ist
das hängt einfach damit zusammen dass
man immer gehofft hat dass er den
angriffskrieg doch nicht startet aber
diese hoffnungen sind zerstört wirklich
zerstört worden nicht alles was ich
kritisches gesagt habe was der besten
gemacht hat irgendwie nato mag ja
stimmen aber es ist von makulatur
geworden weil jetzt eben punkte sich
entschieden hat einen
völkerrechtswidrigen verbrecherischen
angriffskrieg zu führen es gibt schon
tote zivilisten leiden und da gibt es
gar keinen anderen möglichen standpunkt
für eine linkspartei der immer eine
friedenspartei war ist und bleibt als
das schafften zu fördern auch seine
legitimation für diesen an das krieg
also genozid und entnazifizierung ist
also offenkundig völliger blödsinn
also was als erstes in jedem krieg
stirbt das ist die wahrheit das ist
natürlich blöd sind was er da einen
gründer angibt ich darf nur daran
erinnern der irakkrieg von george bush
begann auch mit einer lüge dass die
massenvernichtungswaffen haben das ist
immer so im krieg dass man dann
rechtfertigungen sucht erfindet frei
erfindet darauf darf man sich überhaupt
nicht einlassen das ist wirklich unsinn
ich bin übrigens sie werden sich wundern
diesem fall auch für sanktionen aber für
sanktionen gegen die führung nicht gegen
die bevölkerung man muss das möglichst
ausschließen denn die bevölkerung kann
ja nichts dafür
das ist schwer ich weiß es aber das ist
eine komplizierte abwägung und ist nord
stream zwei eine sanktionen gegen die
führung oder gegen die bevölkerung für
sie
nahm bei nordstream zwei ärgert mich ja
bloß dass hier grün schon immer das
kippen wollten die usa wollten es auch
immer kippen damit wir ihr fracking gas
kaufen und was mich noch mehr ärgert ist
dass die usa erklärt haben die importe
von erdöl aus russland werden um keinen
liter reduziert uns will man zwar vom
gast abschneiden aber sie selber
beziehen nach wie vor die gleiche menge
erdöl aus russland das ist noch ein
anderer punkt im augenblick steht das
nicht zur debatte aber darüber müssen
wir dann später diskutieren weil ich nun
auch nicht einsehen dass die usa von uns
etwas verlangt was sie selber nicht nach
gut einer ganz im gegenteil aber
ansonsten müssen wir uns wirklich
überlegen wie wir putin treffen wie wir
die führung treffen aber möglichst die
bevölkerung verschonen abschalten oder
nicht abschalten jetzt zwölf sondern
nord stream 2
bei dem zwei liegt jetzt auf eis da kann
es jetzt auch liegen und wenn
hoffentlich der krieg irgendwann zu ende
ist wie auch immer dann müssen wir neu
darüber beraten auch mit den usa und
anderen also ich sage nochmal was nicht
geht ist dass wir auf erdgas verzichten
und sie importieren nach wie vor das
gesamte öl das sie benötigen also dass
der zweitgrößte lieferant aus russland
da muss man übereinstimmung es gibt
dramatische flehentliche hilfe appelle
aus der ukraine richtung westen man möge
doch wenn man jetzt wenigstens nicht mit
waffen unterstützen kann und will doch
bitteschön des swift sozusagen russland
abkoppeln von diesem internationalen
finanzsystem ist das für sie auch etwas
was in frage kämen weil sie gesagt haben
das müsste die führung treffen und damit
wäre ja die führung getroffen
ja das problem ist ein anderes natürlich
können wir russland ausschließen aus dem
swift aber es hat ja auch schon ein cdu
politiker darauf hingewiesen dass china
und russland dann ein gemeinsame neuer
währungsstrategen den dollar gegen den
euro ich bin nicht experte genug um das
beurteilen zu können aber das muss man
alles bedenken wissen sie ich habe eine
sorge die komischerweise kaum jemand
anders hat es gibt ja logischerweise
sanktionen gegen russland aber es gibt
ja auch viele sanktionen gegen china was
ich nicht möchte ist das für sie zu
einem bündnis zwingen stellen sie sich
doch mal vor china ist ökonomisch viel
stärker als russland russland ist
militärisch immer noch deutlich stärker
als china wenn die sich wirklich
zusammenschließen entsteht da ein
machtfaktor der für die demokratien für
den westen gar nicht beherrschbar ist
wir müssen lernen zwischen beiden
ländern zu differenzieren um das
möglichst zu verhindern und das hängt
dann auch mit dem swift um mit anderen
dingen zusammen das ist immer schwer
wenn ein krieges wenn es tote gibt wenn
es leid ist diskutiert man noch nicht
gerne über geld und solche sachen nur
wir müssen immer an die konsequenzen und
folgen denken nicht nur an morgen
sondern auch an übermorgen dieser aber
putin glaube ich es erledigt der iss
erledigt und zwar wissen sie bald auch
da hatte er doch immer eine mehrheit in
der russischen bevölkerung ich glaube
die hat er jetzt verloren und die
ukrainische bevölkerung wird widerstand
leisten den er gar nicht kennt sagt der
außenpolitische sprecher der linkspartei
vielen dank gregor gysi
bitteschön
und jetzt in diesen augenblicken
erreicht uns noch eine eilmeldung die
ich ihn eben vorlesen möchte denn
offenbar es gibt bilder bei twitter die
noch nicht verifiziert sind aber
offenbar kann man dort erste russische
militärfahrzeuge in kiew sehen also auch
diese lage müssen wir weiter natürlich
im auge behalten wollen jetzt nochmal
markus kaim den sicherheitsexperten von
der stiftung wissenschaft und politik
bei uns im studio begrüßen sie sind
weiter hin und wieder bei uns halo noch
mal
wenn wir jetzt diese eilmeldung hören
das bedeutet doch der an der masch auf
kiew hat nicht nur begonnen sondern ist
läuft auf vollen hochtouren und das ziel
von putin ist die regierung zu stürzen
und eine pro-russische marionetten
regierung zu installieren ob die
konturen genauso sein werden wissen wir
nicht aber ich glaube die zielrichtung
ist genau richtig vermutet es geht jetzt
um einen enthauptungsschlag es jetzt
nicht im physischen sinne sondern
tatsächlich einmal ein politischer
enthauptung klagt
über kurz oder lang braucht putin ja ein
angenehmes rät riem eine genehme
regierung in
kiew um seinem handeln auch neue
legitimität zu verleihen also im moment
hat handelt gegen die regierung gegen
die bevölkerung und es wäre sehr
hilfreich wäre tatsächlich eine
regierung neuer neue couleur dazu
bewegen könnte das russische vorgehen zu
sanktionieren und das dort zu
bekräftigen zu sagen das war richtig was
ihr getan habt das würde eigentlich auch
einen gesichtswahrenden abzug oder
teilabzug glauben das dürfen wir nicht
vergessen das wäre also sagen jetzt
charmante oder dann wenn eine regierung
installiert ihre instanz könnte das wie
zahlen als heute morgen klingen mag
natürlich die tür öffnet für eine
militärische produktion ich gehe nicht
davon aus dass die russischen truppen
komplett zurückziehen aber vielleicht
gekrümmte standorte zugewiesen bekommen
sozusagen eine nachgeordnete funktion
aber das würde ja nur eintreten wenn es
tatsächlich so was wie kapitulation gibt
auf seiten der ukraine und unsere
reporterin vor ort katrin eigendorf sagt
man solle den widerstand der ukrainische
bevölkerung nicht unterschätzen das mag
man einschätzen wie man will aber was
glauben sie hat die ukraine als staat
überhaupt noch eine chance und rechnen
sie da schon irgendwie in
zeiteinheiten wie lange gibt es die
ukraine noch also es gibt grundsätzlich
zwei vielleicht drei gedanken erste
punkt ist wirklich valide auf den seen
war es letztlich eine gärtnerin ja krieg
auf den könnte es hinauslaufen die usa
habe auch vor wochen schon angekündigt
sie würden den gegebenenfalls
unterstützen wie wirksam der sein könnte
welche auswirkungen der rathaus heutiger
sicht nichts beurteilen dann bleiben
zwei politische optionen wir sehen eine
teilung der ukraine in ost und west teil
der osthalle würde eine sehr sehr enge
politische annäherung vielleicht auch im
rechtlichen sinn an die russische
föderation bekommen oder selber wählen
und der west halb liebe setzt sich als
appendix der europäischen union erhalten
die hatten die zwei sätze lang plus
bereich gehört oder die ukraine würde
als gesamtstaat erhalten bleiben und
dann aber als satellitenstarts russlands
fungieren in dem sinne wie präsident
putin als auch immer gefordert hatte als
pufferstaat als glas jesus sein als
schutz russlands gegenüber der nato er
kann sie selbst haben gestern getwittert
deutschland solle seine haltung zu
waffenlieferungen
überdenken wie genau meint sie das und
was glauben sie auch hier wird die
deutsche bundesregierung mit diesem
thema jetzt doch noch mal angesichts der
neuen lage umgehen die
bundesinnenministerium hat bei uns ja
vorhin gesagt das spielt überhaupt keine
rolle bleibt dass dabei das kann ich
nicht beurteilen sie auch nicht mehr an
mir das zu entscheiden aber ich glaube
in der rückschau wird sich dazu haus
großer fehler herausstellen man ist ja
nie gut beraten im bereich der
sicherheitspolitik dinge auszuschließen
man muss sie nicht laut sagen man muss
sie dann vielleicht nicht letztlich
umsetzen aber dinge ohne not vom tisch
zu nehmen hat sich in vielfältigen
kontext bereits als falsch
herausgestellt dass die bundesregierung
getan ich will das gar nicht bewerten
ich glaube in osteuropa und innerhalb
der nato hat sie damit nicht sonderlich
viel vertrauen geworden also ich glaube
letztlich der ansehensverlust wird sich
noch mal rechnen aber ich sehe im moment
keine politischen mehrheiten für
waffenlieferung und dann bin ich ja
nicht naiv sollte sich das bewahrheiten
was wir zehn mit sich dass wir auf einen
regierungswechsel in kiew zu gestaltet
sich sogar sehr zügig vollziehen könnte
dann stünde die frage im raum an wen
sollen überhaupt liefern und damit ist
das komme ich von der tagesordnung
genommen der außenpolitische sprecher
der linksfraktion gregor gysi war gerade
bei uns im interview warnt vor einer
unheilvollen allianz zwischen dem
ökonomisch starken china und der
militärmacht russland sehen sie das auch
aufziehen wir sehen die bereits das ist
keine militärallianz aber es ist eine
politische allianz die sehr eng sind
zwei kräfte die sich gegen die westliche
ordnung seit 70 jahren haben wenden und
eine alternative ordnungs form vor
vorschlagen das ist eine ortungs form in
der nicht mehr alle gleichberechtigt in
der multilateralen system miteinander
agieren und jedes land an stimmen
sondern letztlich ein ortungssystem die
nach 1815 das wiener kongress ist wo
großmächte einer handvoll von
großmächten die dinge entscheiden das
sieht würde für europa dann so aussehen
aber aus chinesischer perspektive auch
im globalen maßstab und das ist eine
ordnungsamt der europäischen
inkompatibel ist das bedeutet
wahrscheinlich auch wieder eine
rüstungsspirale ost west zumindest kann
man das mutmaßen und sieht es danach aus
jetzt ihr die zentrale frage wäre wenn
wir uns auf diese ordnung einlassen die
ganz andere prinzipien folgt die ehre
geht es dann um raum und militärische
macht dann stellen wir die frage und
diese beginnt für europa im raum wollen
wir in der kategorie von diesen großen
mächten etwas tun denn dafür dass hätte
also erhebliche folgewirkung im
politischen bereich mit mir mit dem ziel
größerer einigkeit zu erzielen und auch
kurze verteidigungs und
sicherheitspolitiker anstrengungen zur
verfolgt zur folge und da stehen wir
erst am anfang der debatte markus kaim
war das von der stiftung wissenschaft
und politik bis hierhin danke für die
analyse jahre
und jetzt live aus berlin das zdf
morgenmagazin
[Musik]
heute im studio variiert von waldenfels
und mitri sirin
guten morgen der auch an diesem tag 2
des krieges von russland gegen die
ukraine natürlich kein guter morgen ist
es gibt aktuelle bilder die wir uns kurz
anschauen können von einem zerstörten
russischen panzer wenn ich das richtig
informiert bin bzw einem fahrzeug einem
russischen dass da im bezirk boland in
kiew unterwegs ist und
dutzende solcher videoschnipsel sind im
internet alle natürlich sehr schwer zu
verifizieren
er zerstörte panzer und damit blicken
wir auf die nächsten bilder gibt es auch
in person eine stadt im süden der
ukraine
nördlich von der halbinsel krim bilder
die wirklich angst machen wenn solche
fahrzeuge durch zivile gegenden fahren
wir blicken jetzt noch mal gemeinsam auf
unsere themen die wir haben
russische einmarsch explosionen und
feuer auch in der ukrainischen
hauptstadt kiew
krisengipfel die eu und deutschland
suchen nach antworten und dann haben wir
noch das sanktionspaket mit welchen
maßnahmen russland jetzt getroffen
werden soll
sie schaut am besten mal auf unsere
heute.de und beziehungsweise in der
mediathek nach finden sie alle möglichen
gesprächsgäste und das waren derer viele
die wir hatten heute den ganzen morgen
und können sich noch einmal über die
aktuelle lage und die statements
informieren wir machen jetzt mit den
nachrichten weiter und mit peanut an
ricoh einen schönen guten morgen jetzt
geht es weiter mit heute express
vielen dank petri und arien guten morgen
und auch ihnen liebe zuschauerinnen und
zuschauer guten morgen die ukrainische
armee liefert sich nach angaben des
generalstabs heftige gefechte mit
russischen truppen ersten meldungen
zufolge sollen sie kiew erreicht haben
der ukrainische aussenminister koller
spricht außerdem von raketenbeschuss in
der hauptstadt twitter videos aus der
nacht sollen einschläge zeigen
wohnhäuser stehen in flammen am morgen
wird die zerstörung dann sichtbar
mehrere gebäude sind stark beschädigt
präsident selensky wirft der russischen
armee vor bei ihren angriffen auch auf
zivile gebiete zu zielen im laufe des
tages rechnet die ukrainische regierung
mit panzern angriffen auf kiew ein
berater des innenministers schrieb auf
telegram die verteidiger stünden mit
abwehrraketen bereit präsident alan ski
hat bereits eine komplette
generalmobilmachung angeordnet männliche
staatsbürger im alter von 18 bis 60
dürfen demnach das land nicht mehr
verlassen
us-außenminister blinken geht davon aus
dass russlands präsident putin die
ukrainische regierung stürzen will am
abend kündigt der us-präsident beiden an
7000 weitere soldaten nach europa zu
verlegen die zunächst in deutschland
stationiert werden sollen diese würden
aber nicht in der ukraine kämpfen
sondern die nato-verbündeten verteidigen
immer mehr länder weltweit verhängen
sanktionen gegen russland in der eu
haben sich die staats und
regierungschefs am abend auf
strafmaßnahmen in den bereichen energie
finanzen und transport geeinigt die
finanz sanktionen zielen auf 70 prozent
des russischen bankenmarkt ab in
russland wurden nach angaben von
bürgerrechtlern mittlerweile mehr als
1700 menschen bei anti kriegs protesten
festgenommen allein in der hauptstadt
moskau seien es knapp 1000 gewesen trotz
eines demonstrationsverbots und
angedrohten harten strafen gingen in
zahlreichen russischen städten menschen
auf die straße
noch nie gab es in deutschland so wenige
verkehrstote wie im vergangenen jahr
laut statistischem bundesamt sind
2569 menschen bei unfällen ums leben
gekommen sechs prozent weniger als im
vorjahr hauptgrund ist demnach das
geringere verkehrsaufkommen infolge der
korona pandemie
und die wetteraussichten die hat
benjamin stufe für uns
donnerwetter das wetter wird ihnen
präsentiert von bett1 de
vielen dank pinner und guten morgen
liebe zuschauerinnen und zuschauer
herzlich willkommen zum wetter heute ist
es noch mal windig bei uns aber nicht
nur bei uns richtung grönland und island
voller orkan bei uns ins die
tiefdruckgebiete über skandinavien die
noch mal für einen sehr lebhaften
teilweise stürmischen wind sorgen
perspektivisch ist es aber hier das
hochdruckgebiet das von der biscaya mehr
und mehr in unsere richtung strebt das
wochenende wird sonnig trocken und
überwiegend wind stellen aber erst mal
der blick zurück auf die vergangenen 12
stunden die fast der radar film zusammen
da gab es schnee da gab es wegen
zwischen einem und zehn liter auf den
quadratmeter
das klingt jetzt meistens ab aber sie
sehen von nordwesten drängt es da schon
wieder hinein und das was uns da
entgegenkommt ist richtiges aprilwetter
bei temperaturen zum start in den tag
zwischen -3 grad in neuhaus am rennweg
in thüringen sechs grad plus meldet
heute morgen wüst und der vormittag im
überblick der held viele sonnige momente
parat von der ostseeküste in einer
großen kurve bis zum schwarzwald im
südosten kriegen die schneeschauer ab
aber von westen wird es dichter und
spätestens zum nachmittag für uns alle
bestes april wetter mit regen schnee
graupel und auch dem einen oder dem
anderen gewitter im umfeld dieser
gewitter stürmische böen im bereich des
möglichen das ganze bei
tageshöchsttemperaturen heute zwischen
drei grad richtung östlichen
mittelgebirge und am alpenrand bis 10
grad am oberrhein jetzt der blick auf
die hochdruck geprägten aussichten für
die kommenden drei tage morgen
verklingen die schneeschauer bei zwei
bis neun grad und wird es von tag zu tag
trockener und sonniger ab montag auch
wieder milder vier bis zwölf grad zum
beginn der neuen woche soweit zum wetter
für den moment kommen sie mit diesen
aussichten jetzt gut in den freitag
donnerwetter das wetter wurde ihnen
präsentiert von bett1 de
guten morgen von uns beiden der
natürlich auch am tag zwei der
kriegerischen katastrophe kein guter
morgen ist wir informieren sie schon
seit 5 uhr 30 live mit diversen
gesprächspartnern und schalten und
es gibt diese meldung und vor allem auch
diese bilder die wir ihnen jetzt zeigen
wollen liebe zuschauerinnen und
zuschauer uns hat die meldung erreicht
dass nach russlands einmarsch in die
ukraine jetzt nach angaben des
ukrainischen
verteidigungsministeriums die ersten
russischen militärfahrzeuge hier sehen
wie sie in den bildern tatsächlich in
kiew angekommen das soll in polen sein
das ist ein örtlicher stadtteil und wie
verzweifelt man ist verdeutlicht dieser
tweet des ukrainischen
verteidigungsministeriums die zivilisten
auffordern hören sie mal zu molotow
cocktails gegen russische panzer
einzusetzen macht molotov cocktails
neutralisiert die besatzer heißt es in
diesem ziel des ukrainischen
verteidigungsministeriums die ereignisse
überschlagen sich eine teilweise noch
unübersichtliche lage annette streicher
und dank freier fassen jetzt die
aktuelle situation noch einmal für sie
zusammen
zerstörung rauch und feuer in einem
wohngebiet mittlerweile rücken russische
truppen auch ins gebiet um kiew vor die
nacht und der frühe morgen in der
ukrainischen hauptstadt wurden von
lauten explosionen zerrissen
raketenbeschuss aus kiew die ukrainische
armee gibt an zwei davon im flug
zerstört zu haben veröffentlicht ein
amateurvideo ein wohnhaus geht in
flammen auf immer wieder sirenen die
ukrainische zivilbevölkerung nach der
ersten kriegs nacht in schrecken und
todesangst versetzt tausende haben
schutz gesucht in u bahnhöfen
wir waren nicht darauf vorbereitet zu
fliehen niemand hatte mit dem
kriegsbeginn gerechnet und dass sie
direkt kiew angreifen würden
man wusste in der panik gar nicht wohin
und wie man sich verhalten sollte die
menschen unter schock ungläubig viele
versuchen zu fliehen dass der andrang an
den grenzen zu den europäischen
nachbarstaaten bisher nicht noch größer
war mag daran liegen dass es vielerorts
schwer war voranzukommen seit dem
gestrigen morgen rollt die russische
militär offensive von mehreren flanken
diese rakete schlug in einem wohngebiet
von kiew ein was haben die ukrainischen
streitkräfte dem entgegenzusetzen
der ukrainische präsident see lenski
organisiert nach eigenen worten aus kiew
heraus den widerstand seine worte ein
verzweifelter appell
ich habe 27 staats und regierungschefs
gefragt ob die ukraine in der nato sein
können ich habe direkt gefragt alle
haben angst keiner antwortet mir
am späten abend hatte er eine allgemeine
mobilmachung angeordnet russland hatte
behauptet nur gegen militäreinrichtungen
vorzugehen doch nach den worten des
ukrainischen präsidenten aus der nacht
werden längst auch zivile ziele
beschossen kolonnen rücken auf die
hauptstadt vor
ich bin hauptsächlich müde und
verängstigt es ist ein ausnahmezustand
nichts davon fühlt sich real an keine
ahnung wie ich das alles einordnen soll
eu-kommissionspräsident in ursula von
der leyen sagt heute früh nach stunden
der beratungen der eu staats und
regierungschefs dass der kreml zur
rechenschaft gezogen werde man habe sich
auf massive sanktionen geeinigt die auf
70 prozent des russischen bankenmarkt
abzielen auch der ausschluss russlands
aus dem internationalen währungssystem
swift könne jetzt noch kommen sagte der
luxemburgische außenminister dazu im zdf
das trifft ist nicht vom tisch wir haben
heute mittag sind die außenminister
zusammen wenn diese bombardierung von
kiews weiter geht wenn der präsident sie
denn zumal sein leben fürchten muss ich
glaube dann kommt alles auf den tisch
man muss nur wissen wen man trifft
am nachmittag berät erneut auch die nato
auf einem krisengipfel über diese
russische offensive wie sie europa seit
langem nicht gesehen hat
schwere wirklich bittere stunden für die
ukraine und steht schlimmste zu
befürchten und die truppen die
russischen rücken eben immer weiter vor
und man muss nach allem was man jetzt an
agenturen und nachrichten hier liest und
sieht
wohl befürchten dass kiew bald
eingenommen werden könnte wir fragen
nach bei unserer korrespondentin inna
moskau bei anna feist und würden gerne
wissen von ihnen was gibt es denn für
aktuelle meldungen aus dem kreml
ja bisher aus dem kreml noch keine neuen
meldungen
dafür weitere meldungen aus den
russischen agenturen und was spannend
ist und was auffällt ist dass in den
russischen agenturmeldungen eben die
besetzung oder der angriff auf kiew
keine rolle spielt was eine rolle spielt
sind ist der donbass der osten der
ukraine es wird vermeldet dass die
prorussischen separatisten und an ihrer
seite die russischen streitkräfte immer
mehr städte wohl einnehmen sollen in der
donbass region
und gleichzeitig wird vermeldet wie das
ukrainische militär rücksichtslos eben
auch zivile ziele wie schulen zb
angreift an diesem morgen soll eine
schule durch ein wurfgeschoss zerstört
worden sein zwei lehrer seien da getötet
worden und das bedient natürlich ganz
klar dass sehr aktiv was putin hier
etabliert hat nämlich dass es einen
angeblichen völkermord im osten der
ukraine gibt den putin nun beenden wird
und dieses russischstämmige volk da eben
befreien will auch aus den fängen des
rücksichtslosen ukrainischen militärs
gleichzeitig wird heute etwas anderes
obwohl noch eine rolle spielen nämlich
wurde gestern vermeldet dass der
nördliche krim kanal eingenommen wurde
der ist wesentlich und essentiell für
die wasserversorgung auf der krim die
schon lange ein problem darstellt und um
diesen krim kanal geht es auch um die 1
der städte harrisson und milito pol
beide städte strategisch wichtig um eine
landverbindung zwischen grimm und
donners zu schaffen das sind die
meldungen die jetzt hier in diesen
minuten eine rolle spielen es ist ja
ganz interessant was ihr gerade anfangs
auch gesagt haben für uns hier in
deutschland zum beispiel ist es oft auch
schwierig an verifizierte an bestätigte
informationen zu kommen wie sieht das in
russland aus in russland aus wie es da
der informationsfluss welche quellen
nutzen sie
das ist natürlich problematisch es gab
hier gestern eine meldung vom presse-
und informationsdienst wo lokale
journalisten angewiesen wurden
detailliert nur material zu benutzen bei
dieser kriegsberichterstattung das eben
aus staatlichen quellen stammt was wir
haben ja hier eine breitere quellen
zufuhr weil wir eben auch deutsche und
internationale quellen benutzen aber wir
haben natürlich auch ein großes problem
zu verifizieren was denn nun stimmt und
was nun nicht stimmt und man kann eben
ganz klar beobachten wie die russischen
agenturen andere dinge wiedergeben als
unsere internationalen agenturen und da
ein konkretes beispiel wir haben dich
hier zahlen bekommen gestern abend gab
es ja anti kriegs proteste in moskau wir
haben hier zahlen das
1797 menschen wohl festgenommen wurden
die russischen agenturen vermeldeten
dass es ich glaube es waren um die 700
menschen festgenommen wurden und das ist
natürlich ein eklatanter unterschied
annafest mit informationen aus moskau
danke sehr
es gibt aktuelle meldungen zum beispiel
von der nachrichtenagentur ap die meldet
schüsse nahe der regierungszentrale in
kiew zu hören das heißt die russischen
kräfte sind offenbar wirklich nicht mehr
weit entfernt und das betrifft das hat
uns heute morgen auch unsere reporterin
katrin eigendorf bestätigt der russische
spione und saboteure die sich sozusagen
mit ukrainischen fahrzeugen getarnt
immer weiter in richtung
regierungszentrale bewegen wir gehen
jetzt in den westen landes nach lemberg
und dort ist für uns schon die ganze
zeit lothar becker was hören sie denn
über die aktuellen dramatischen
ereignisse in kiew
ich habe aufnahmen gesehen die aus china
stammen sollen bei denen man sieht wie
panzer bereits durch diese europäische
metropole rollen welche schäden genau im
moment dort vermeldet werden welche
fortschritte genau das ist hier aus
lemberg schwer zu beurteilen ich weiß
von einem kontakt in kiew dass es in der
nacht eben zum abschluss eines
russischen flugzeugs gekommen ist das
flugzeug ist dann auch privathäuser
gestürzt das wurde mir persönlich
berichtet und gleichzeitig ist auch
nicht klar ob teile des flugzeugs oder
möglicherweise auch trümmerteile oder
raketen nach ein appartement gebäude
getroffen haben gleichzeitig haben wir
hier in lemberg in der nacht beobachtet
wie immer mehr menschen die stadt
verlassen wollen wir sind hier recht nah
an der polnischen aber auch slowakischen
grenze in der nacht in der straße hinter
mir wurden dann koffer in autos gepackt
und menschen sind losgefahren und heute
morgen als wir wieder hier waren
beobachteten wie ein
entschärfungskommando
hier der polizei oder der streitkräfte
sich um eine tasche kümmern musste die
hier stehen geblieben ist weil man
einfach nicht wusste ob es sich
möglicherweise um eine sprengfalle
handelt also auch hier in lemberg ist
man sehr darauf bedacht darauf acht zu
geben ob es möglicherweise auch hier
sabotageakte geben könnte das hat sich
dann herausgestellt dass es tatsächlich
nur eine vergessene tasche war
allerdings in der nähe von lemberg
befindet sich wohl eine panzerfabrik da
gab es heute morgen die wanderung an die
bevölkerung sich davon fernzuhalten weil
es natürlich möglicherweise ein
taktisches ziel sein könnte es gibt
dramatische öffentliche appelle seitens
der ukrainische politik der
außenminister der twittert der
ukrainische präsident der sich mit
videos an die bevölkerung richtet die
konsumieren die menschen in lemberg
nachrichten wie kommt das an was die
staatsführung ihren bürgerinnen und
bürgern empfiehlt
zum einen schützt das engste zum anderen
meine ich gerade eben auch eine
detonation in einer gewissen entfernung
gehört zu haben ich kann das jetzt nicht
genau verifizieren es wird auf jeden
fall klar dieser lage im land ist
dramatisch und das vermittelt auch die
regierung an die menschen generell die
allgemeine mobilmachung heute nacht das
alle wehrfähigen männer zwischen 18 und
60 das land eben nicht verlassen dürfen
das sind ganz klar natürlich dinge die
auch hier in lemberg in der stadt die am
weitesten vom donders entfernt ist
gehört werden und die auch die menschen
natürlich verunsichern der einzige
vorteil ist die grenzen sind offen nach
polen und der slowakei ich weiß dort vor
ort gibt es auch menschen die zum
beispiel aus deutschland in die slowakei
gefahren sind in der letzten nacht um
menschen abzuholen und sie in sicherheit
zu bringen
die grenzübergänge werden teilweise zu
fuß überquert weil es eben der vor lange
staus gibt und auch wir lösen jetzt hier
diesen standort lemberg auf und werden
uns in den nächsten stunden an die
polnische grenze wahrscheinlich begeben
und werden die ukraine verlassen geben
sie auf sich acht lothar becker vielen
dank nach lemberg
wir haben es gehört diese wirklich
furchtbaren ereignisse führen eben dazu
dass sich zahlreiche menschen in
bewegung setzen wir haben die bilder
gesehen und ihnen auch gezeigt liebe
zuschauer von lange langen autoschlangen
und staus wie die menschen versuchen
raus aus den städten mehr in die
ländlichen regionen aber nicht nur das
vor allen dingen eben auch mehr in
richtung nachbarland polen
beispielsweise zu fliehen deshalb wollen
wir jetzt schalten zu unserer dortigen
korrespondentin zu natalie steger die
direkt in einem ort hinter der
ukrainischen grenze sich befindet
natalie wo genau sind sie und was
erwartet die flüchtlinge dort
wir sind hier am bahnhof in churchill
das ist ein ort etwa 10 15 kilometer von
der grenze entfernt und hier kommen
immer noch menschen an bezügen aus kiew
gestern waren es hunderte in der nacht
kam ein zug an auch heute sind noch züge
aus kiew angekündigt aber dann muss man
natürlich erstmal sehen wie die menschen
jetzt aus dieser stadt nach dem stand
der dinge überhaupt rauskommen was die
menschen hier erwartet nun sie werden
ziemlich herzlich aufgenommen mit
schokolade versorgt mit wasser mit essen
und hier haben die polnischen behörden
einen infopunkt eingerichtet da kann man
sich hinwenden man erfährt dort wie man
weiter kommt wo man hin kann viele
wollen ja weiter in europa weil sie
verwandte haben wir waren heute morgen
auch an der autobahn am übergang da gibt
es wie sie gesagt haben auf der anderen
seite lange staus 1000 autos haben die
polnischen grenzbehörden uns gesagt zwei
junge frauen aus kiew die haben es
geschafft die sind rübergekommen nach
zehn stunden wartezeit aber insgesamt
muss man sagen die polen nehmen auch die
grenzschützer man nimmt die menschen
hier ziemlich unbürokratisch auf man
sagt auch ohne reisepass beziehungsweise
mit abgelaufenem darf man rein der
polnische gesundheitsminister hat gesagt
die menschen die hier ankommen die im
ganzen land ankommen die werden
natürlich auch medizinisch versorgt so
es denn nötig ist ja was fast ein
bisschen eine erschreckende nachricht
ist man sagt wenn die ukraine ihre
verletzten nicht mehr behandeln kann
dann steht polen bereit zu helfen und
ist polen auch auf eine wirklich große
massive flucht bewegung aus der ukraine
vorbereitet in welchen größenordnungen
auch denkt man da
ja man hat vor dieser richtig großen
offensive dieser massiven mit dem er
nicht gerechnet dass das sie so massiv
ist hat man bis drei bis fünf millionen
menschen die fliegen gerechnet ja ob man
sich darauf vorbereiten kann wenn es
noch mehr menschen sind das muss man
abwarten aber polen hat sich vorbereitet
wochenlang gab es pläne der regierung
gab es aufrufe an die botschaften an die
regionen den menschen im falle eines
russischen angriffs zu helfen den
ukrainern die hierher kommen und es sind
wirklich mehrere
anlaufpunkte hier eingerichtet worden
also insgesamt sind die polin die an
sich nicht der flüchtlings freundlich
sind in diesem falle sehr herzlich und
sagen wir müssen unseren nachbarn helfen
das haben wir auch von privatleuten
gehört die zur trend zu fahren auf
polnischer seite und den leuten plätze
anbieten damit man sie transportieren
kann natalie steger war das mit
informationen aus polen vielen dank
wir schauen jetzt auf die reaktionen in
deutschland sie haben sicherlich die
ansprache des bundeskanzlers gesehen
putin wird nicht gewinnen es ist putins
krieg und nicht der des russischen
volkes das war eine deutliche botschaft
ja man ist also entschieden harte
sanktionen gegen russland soll es geben
die volle solidarität die ist mit der
ukraine die sonstigen reaktionen aus
deutschland die fast jan fritsche
zusammen
für die demonstranten gestern vor dem
kanzleramt ist klar was zu tun ist putin
stoppen mit maximalen sanktionen gegen
russland und waffenlieferungen an die
ukraine
eine ukrainische flagge auch im
kanzleramt doch viel mehr als
solidarität will der hausherr dem land
nicht zu sagen betont stattdessen in
einer fernsehansprache der krieg dürfe
sich nicht weiter ausdehnen
putin sollte die entschlossenheit der
nato nicht unterschätzen alle ihre
mitglieder zu verteidigen das gilt
ausdrücklich für unsere nato partner im
baltikum in polen und in rumänien in
bulgarien und in der slowakei ohne wenn
und aber
außenministerin bernburg wirft putin im
zdf-interview wahnvorstellungen vor sie
und kanzler stolz sein von ihm angelogen
worden daneben fordert die grüne
außenministerin eine bessere ausstattung
fürs militär
wir erleben aber wenn wir die bundeswehr
anschauen zum beispiel dass wir mit
blick auf material natürlich deutlich
deutlich mehr machen müssen deutlich
mehr machen das sieht beim thema
verteidigung auch der
bundesfinanzminister so in der
vergangenheit sei die truppe
vernachlässigt worden
es gab eine friedensdividende das heißt
wir hatten nach dem ende des kalten
krieges das gefühl das brauchen wir
nicht mehr andere übernehmen die lasten
etwa die vereinigten staaten die union
hat sich an tag eins des krieges hinter
den kurs der ampel regierung gestellt
nur beim thema waffenlieferungen gibt es
bei manch einem einen sinneswandel
es ist jetzt richtig weil nicht mehr
gesprochen wird dass auch deutschland
die ukraine durch lieferung von
militärischer ausrüstung unterstützt in
der deutschen politik hat ein umdenken
begonnen beim umgang mit autoritären
staaten doch für die ukraine dürfte das
zuspätkommen
in der deutschen politik hat ein
umdenken begonnen ich weiß nicht ob das
auch für das schärfste schwert bei den
sanktionen gilt darüber wollen wir unter
anderem jetzt sprechen mit thomas
reichert im hauptstadtstudio noch mal
einen guten morgen thomas es wirft das
ist das schärfste schwert das ist ein
internationales transaktions system und
da möchte man russland abkoppeln das ist
der dringende wunsch der ukraine um
wenigstens etwas zu tun aber der kanzler
weigert sich noch muss man sagen wie
schätzt du die situation
also die diskussion hat sich an fahrt
aufgenommen sowohl in politischer als
auch im europäischen rahmen gestern
abend gab es da nicht nur von deutscher
seite sondern auch von anderen
europäischen ländern noch vorbehalte
dagegen dass dieses scharfe schwert
tatsächlich zu zücken heute treffen sich
die eu finanzminister in paris und
christian lindner hat da eben gesagt
dass swift nach wie vor dem tisch liegt
ähnlich hat sich der luxemburgische
außenminister geäußert mit blick auf ein
treffen der eu außenminister heute
nachmittag in brüssel es ist natürlich
auch eine frage dessen wie stellt sich
deutschland diese solidarität die sg und
der ukraine verkündet hat dann nun
tatsächlich da und vor
kanzler scholz hat ja beim thema nord
zum zwei lange gezögert sich ist lange
im ungefähren geblieben und erst am
dienstag dann bei der anerkennung der
separatisten republiken durch putin
hatte diesen schritt verkündet ein held
ist es ähnlich scheint sich nun bei
swift abzuzeichnen es ist natürlich auch
das problem dass dann gaslieferungen aus
russland schwere zu bezahlen sind die eu
argumentiert im moment noch dass die
sanktionen die bereits verabschiedet
wurden ein sehr scharfes schwert sind
und die
russische wirtschaft und den banken
verkehr weitgehend zum erliegen bringen
würden wir haben heute morgen auch
erfahren dass deutschland mit waffen mit
truppen die ost nato flanke weiter
stärken weiter unterstützen möchte also
militärische abschreckung ist ein mittel
der wahl jetzt auch für den kanzler na
ja er hat ja gestern in seiner ansprache
deutlich gemacht dass diese solidarität
und die unterstützung ausdrücklich
besonders für die osteuropäischen länder
geht und das bedeutet natürlich auch
dass deutschland dann mit der bundeswehr
weitere verantwortung übernehmen wird
das ist sowieso schon eingeplant
deutschland wird dann in diesem jahr ein
ganz erhebliches kontingent bei der nato
eingreiftruppe stellen über 13.000 mann
drei eurofighter sind gestern nach
rumänien auf dem luftwaffenstützpunkt
konstanzer verlegt worden die sollen
dort in den luftraum über dem schwarzen
meer an der nato südostflanke überwachen
aber klar ist auch dass diese
solidarität die shoah gestern verkündet
hat
in wirklichkeit steckt bei der
bundeswehr nicht ganz schafft wenn die
bundeswehr ist in keinem guten zustand
der heeresinspekteur hat gestern alarm
geschlagen hat gesagt wir stehen quasi
blank da die mittelfristige
finanzplanung für die olaf scholz noch
als finanzminister der großen koalition
zuständig war sieht für die nächsten
jahre tatsächlich ein abschmelzen des
militärbudgets über mehrere milliarden
vor da ist nun in berlin eine trendwende
angesichts der aktuellen entwicklungen
zu sehen es wird wahrscheinlich mehr
geld für militärische rüstung geben aber
nochmal das braucht natürlich zeit bis
das wieder so stark ist dass die
bundeswehr wirklich den worten taten
folgen kann und wirkliche solidarität
mit den ost europäischen rates stärken
zeigen kann es ist jetzt nicht die zeit
für diplomatie hat man auch gehört von
politik also die plakative drosseln
obwohl frankreichs präsident das
offenbar gestern noch einmal versucht
hat sonntag wird es eine sondersitzung
des bundestages geben es sind
dramatische zeiten vielleicht kurze
antwort thomas womit muss man rechnen
was es zu erwarten es wird denn die
regierungserklärung von kasseler scholz
geben danach ist eine aussprache von
etwa 90 minuten geplant ich würde
erwarten dass sich zeigen wird dass alle
parteien im parlament da zusammenrücken
das hat die union angekündigt das ist
auch von von der linken zu sehen gregor
gysi hat er sozusagen ist als fehler
bezeichnet dass man lange auf seiten der
linken so getan hat als wäre diese diese
in version 1 irgend gespenstes bestens
also ich glaube am sonntag werden die
ein großes zusammenrücken sehen in einer
wenn ich der größten krise
außenpolitischen krise die
bundesrepublik seit ihrem bestehen
durchmacht danke für die einschätzung
unserer hauptstadt korrespondent thomas
reichert war das danke
ja es sind schwere stunden für uns alle
in erster linie selbstverständlich für
die menschen in der ukraine wir wollen
ihnen zum schluss dieser sendung noch
einmal ein paar bilder zeigen die uns
aus der ukraine erreicht haben denn wir
haben ja gehört und ihn schon vermeldet
es gibt panzer sogar mittlerweile in der
ukrainischen hauptstadt in kiew hier
sehen wir die entsprechenden bilder wie
die russischen truppen bis nach kiew
vorgegeben sind das wird auch vom
regierungsviertel behauptet dass truppen
dort allerdings in ukrainischen
fahrzeugen sich den zentrum immer nähern
sollen und da darf man also ableiten
möglicherweise dass das ziel
logischerweise der präsident ist wo der
sich augenblicklich befindet ist
natürlich ein großes geheimnis ich denke
er wird sich natürlich in sicherheit
gebracht haben und wir haben noch
weitere bilder und zwar sehen wir unter
anderem
dieses ein von einem panzer überrollt
auto
und für sie zur information das müsste
gleichkommen der fahrer dieses autos
konnte glücklicherweise gerettet werden
hier sind die bilder das ganze auch rund
um tiere gleich im anschluss an unsere
sendung ein zdf spezial wir senden
übrigens auch morgen und am sonntag
morgen sind wir dran von sieben bis neun
übermorgen die ard kollegen also bleiben
sie bei uns wünschen ihnen alles gute
alle weiteren informationen hier
natürlich den ganzen tag über im zdf und
wir empfehlen für laufende informationen
natürlich die kollegen der zdf heute
dort wenn sie alles kurz und kompakt das
was von uns danke fürs zuschauen
[Musik]
bleiben sie immer aktuell informiert im
zdf und die zdf-reihe
wind sind wann ein ausnahme künstler
zwischen genie und wahnsinn
ein leben voller tragödien damen und
unglaublichen werten
lang verkannt ist er heute einer der
berühmtesten maler der welt
terrex sonntag 19.30 im zdf
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zu einem heute
spezial an diesem tag 2 des russischen
angriff auf die ukraine in der
hauptstadt kiew sind in der nacht
explosionen zu hören das ukrainische
militär berichtet von erbitterten
kämpfen nordwestlich von kiew russland
plant offenbar nicht nur von osten und
vom süden der krim aus vorzurücken
sondern vor allem von norden her nach
kiew durchzubrechen das strategische
ziel offenbar die hauptstadt einzunehmen
dort holen heute morgen die sirenen die
schäden deutlich zu sehen heute wird der
härteste tag sagte ein berater des
ukrainischen innenministeriums
versuchen in den nächsten eineinhalb
stunden die lage zu klären fakten und
informationen zusammenzutragen und die
situation zu analysieren
lothar becker mein kollege war bislang
in lemberg musste aber auch diese große
stadt im westen der ukraine verlassen
ist jetzt per live view mit uns
verbunden lothar erste frage wo bist du
wie ist die lage
ja wir sind sozusagen beim packen die
kamera ist bereits verstaut das team
bereiten sich vor damit wir uns hier
möglichst schnell auch in richtung
polnische grenze aufmachen können
ausreichen es gab hier am morgen auch
wieder serien in lemberg es gibt hier in
der nähe eine panzerfabrik die
möglicherweise zweiten klasse sein
könnte
es gab geräusche druckwellen die
möglicherweise auf die formation
hindeuten allerdings in einiger
entfernung in kiew ist die situation
schon viel näher diese große europäische
metropole mit drei millionen einwohnern
erlebt jeden aktiven krieg es ist eben
kein
gezieltes schießen militärische
stützpunkte mehr wie es vielleicht zu
anfang war sondern es ist ein krieg auch
ein krieg gegen die bevölkerung denn der
millionenstädte angreift der weiß dass
das gar nicht möglich ist so etwas ohne
zivile opfer irgendwie zu schaffen in
der nacht das haben mehr menschen aus
kiel
berichtet haben sie beobachtet wie wohl
ein russisches flugzeug von der
ukrainischen flugabwehr abgeschossen
wurde dann auch privatgebäude in ihr
stürzt ist lackmann und eben auch
möglicherweise noch oder trümmerteile
zumindest ein appartement gebäude
getroffen haben die
generalmobilmachung die allgemeine
immobilie machen fia-präsident zellen in
der nacht ausgerufen weil der
wehrfähigen männer zwischen 18 und 60
dürfen auf die ukraine nicht verlassen
und werden zu den großen teilweise wurde
sogar empfohlen molotow-cocktails das
haben wir gehört zumindest
wirklich einzusetzen also alles zu tun
um zu verhindern
dass hier ein genommen wird auf das
gelingt ob das möglich ist ja
widersprechen sich die meldungen jutta
es ist ja schwierig von lemberg aus die
situation in der gesamten ukraine wieder
zu geben aber gibt es denn irgendein
bild eigentlich von den angriffen wo die
russischen truppen jetzt genau stehen
wir hören eben wenige kilometer von kiew
entfernt
kirche ist eine große metropole und 20
kilometer im kern von kiew da ist mein
gefühl schon fast in kiew sind wohl
gezielt stützpunkte militärstützpunkte
gewesen die angegriffen wurden es am
morgen auch dass der flughafen von kers
ein mögliches ziel für luftlandetruppen
sein könnte um eben daraus einen
brückenkopf für weitere
zwei weitere truppenteile der russen zu
bilden das heißt dass man dann den
zivilen flughafen nutzen könnte das kann
sein das kann eine taktik sein
offensichtlich ist es so dass eben die
russischen bodentruppen von norden her
das ist eben der kürzeste weg von der
belarussische grenze auch tschernobyl an
tschernobyl vorbei das ist ja auch
besetzt worden sich in richtung hier
aufgemacht haben in der nacht und eben
diese weiteren raketenbeschüsse dann
heute früh gegen 4 halb fünf ortszeit
haben dann wohl diese nächste stufe
eingeleitet
ziel scheint das regierungsviertel in
kiew zu sein putin spricht ja von einem
regime
und möglicherweise oft bahnen durch
einen schnellen zugriff auf die
regierungsgebäude und auf die nation
selber auf den präsidenten hier einen
erfolg vermelden zu können allerdings
scheint die ukraine sich so gut sie eben
an zu wehren
aufzuhalten tanzer truppen aufzuhalten
vermeldet immer wieder erfolge ob das
eine verzögerung ist oder auch dass
tatsächlich etwas aufhellt in diesem
vormarsch das werden wir erst in den
nächsten stunden wissen luther ist es
völlig klar dass er schwer einzuordnen
ist aber man hat ja von außen den
eindruck dass die russischen
streitkräfte anscheinend erfolgreich die
ukrainische luftwaffe ausgeschaltet
haben also in den frühen morgenstunden
gestern bombardements der der runways
also der militärischen flughäfen hast du
denn habt ihr denn irgendwann überhaupt
mal ukrainische luftwaffe am himmel
gesehen
wir selber haben sie nicht gesehen aber
wir haben sie ihn gehört haben wenige
tage vor dem angriff selber auf einem
luftwaffenstützpunkt interviews führen
können mit piloten und kommandeuren der
kontakt dorthin der direkte kontakt
abgebrochen hat man dort auch sicherlich
andere interessen als unbedingt mit der
deutschen presse zu sprechen aber die
gespräche die wir dort gefühlt haben die
interviews die dort geführt haben haben
mir klar gemacht man hat die finnische
luftwaffe in den letzten jahren
ausgebaut man wusste dass so ein tag ist
ein mal kommen würde möglich
würde aber man wusste auch in der sat 1
pilot dort direkt bestätigt nicht die
ersten die es treffen wird sie wussten
wenn die russen einmarschieren dann
müssen sie die ukrainische luftwaffe so
schnell wie möglich dezimieren davon
abhalten gegen vormarsch eben zu
unterbrechen das ging so weit dass es
meldungen gibt dass gestern ein
ukrainisches flugzeug ein kampfjet eine
su-27 das sind große kampfjets aus
sowjetischer zeit zumindest optisch der
bauart eben nicht mal mehr in der
ukraine offensichtlich landen konnte und
deswegen nach rumänien geflogen ist um
dort die maschine sicher landen zu
können also dieser erste schlag gestern
auf die luftwaffenstützpunkte
scheint erfolgreich gewesen lothar du
hast gesagt es gibt die aufforderung
dass die menschen die ukraine die
bevölkerung von k s selbst mit
molotow-cocktails sozusagen die stadt
verteidigen sollen wie ist denn die
stimmung bei den menschen ist da eine
bereitschaft wirklich die heimat zu
verteidigen sind da jetzt männer die dem
aufruf folgen und sagen wir nehmen das
gewehr in die hand was die letzte jahr
in seiner rede angeboten hat jeder der
zwischen 18 und 60 ist bekommt ein
gewehr um die ukraine zu verteidigen ist
da diese stimmung bei den ukrainern ja
das tun wir
im moment haben sie im grunde genommen
keine wahl in der zeit vor dem angriff
hatte ich eine sehr große
verteidigungsbereitschaft bei den
menschen beobachtet durch die
generationen und geschlechtern weg waren
alle der meinung wir geben nicht einfach
auf wir wollen unsere unabhängigkeit
unsere freiheit unser land und unsere
familien verteidigen und diese
reihenfolge hat mich erstaunt das ist
etwas was wir uns sicherlich in
deutschland so nur schwer vorstellen
können aber gegen menschen in der
ukraine ist ihre freiheit so wichtig
dass sie gesagt haben nein egal wie groß
dieser gegner ist wir werden nicht
kampflos aufgeben wie das dann ist wenn
die explosionen näher kommen wenn anzahl
wollen das kann sich jeder
wahrscheinlich selber ausmalen und es
gibt viele tausende vielleicht mehrere
zehntausende vielleicht auch
sechsstellige zahlen die jetzt kursieren
werden in den kommenden tagen von
menschen die das land eben verlassen
wollen weil sie angst haben
der flächendeckende
angriff mit ballistischen raketen
hinterlässt nicht nur spuren im land
sondern auch in den in den köpfen in den
herzen in den seelen der menschen denn
natürlich fühlt sich niemand in
irgendeiner form sicher wenn so ein
angriff überhaupt nicht bemerkt wird bis
zu dem bruchteil der sekunde der
stattfindet und man im grunde genommen
nichts dagegen tun kann außer sich von
möglichen zielen fern zu halten und zu
hoffen dass keine dieser raketen
fehlgeleitet irgendwo in einer stadt
einschlägt was viele menschen machen ist
wenn sie nicht die ukraine setzt ganz
verlassen dass sie doch zumindest
versuchen ausland hinauszufahren
verwandte zu besuchen und sich dort
irgendwie in sicherheit zu bringen die
eigene sicherheit bis im moment für
viele die nicht
dienst an der waffe antreten sicherlich
das wichtigste wird sein notar vielen
vielen dank für diese vielen vielen
frischen informationen und vor allen
dingen für diese eindrücklichen
schilderung vielen dank
die ukrainische führung rechnet mit
einem panzerangriff auf kiew das sieht
die us-regierung genauso der
amerikanische außenminister blinken
erklärte kiew könne womöglich belagert
werden ziel des russischen präsidenten
putin sei offenbar die prowestliche
seelands die regierung zu stürzen aus
der ukraine selbst erreichen uns viele
bilder einen überblick nun über das was
wir aus dem land erfahren von christoph
gockel
kiew heute morgen in diesem wohnviertel
der ukrainischen hauptstadt ist eine
rakete eingeschlagen
die städtische feuerwehr ist vor ort und
versucht zu löschen
innen sieht es jetzt so aus viele
wohnungen sind zerstört ein bewohner
berichtet
es gab einen knall etwas flog über uns
ich kam zum fenster und sah zunächst
nichts nach der explosion hatte ich von
dort einen guten blick ich konnte sehen
wie fenster teile von beiden seiten
herunterfielen zum glück wurde niemand
verletzt
ein amateurvideo zeigt wie das wohnhaus
in der nacht den flyer steht die nacht
und der frühe morgen in der
millionenstadt wurden von lauten
explosionen zirkussen immer wieder
raketen beschuss die ukrainische armee
gibt an zwei davon im flug zerstört zu
haben immer wieder sirenen die die
ukrainische zivilbevölkerung in der
hauptstadt in schrecken und todesangst
versetzt tausende haben schutz gesucht
in u bahnhöfen
wir waren nicht darauf vorbereitet zu
fliehen niemand hatte mit dem
kriegsbeginn gerechnet und dass sie
direkt angreifen würden
man wusste in der panik gar nicht wohin
und wie man sich verhalten sollte die
menschen unter schock ungläubig viele
versuchen zu fliehen dass der andrang an
den grenzen zu den europäischen
nachbarstaaten im westen bisher nicht
noch größer war mag daran liegen dass es
vielerorts schwer ist voranzukommen seit
dem gestrigen morgen rollt die russische
militär offensive von mehreren flanken
diese rakete schlug in einem wohngebiet
von kiew allen nun was haben die
ukrainischen streitkräfte dem
entgegenzusetzen der präsident
organisiert nach eigenen worten aus kiew
heraus den widerstand seine worte ein
verzweifelter appell
ich habe 27 staats und regierungschefs
gefragt ob die ukraine in der nato sein
kann ich habe direkt gefragt alle haben
angst keiner antwortet mir
am späten abend hatte er eine allgemeine
mobilmachung angeordnet russland hatte
behauptet nur gegen militäreinrichtungen
vorzugehen doch nach den worten des
ukrainischen präsidenten aus der nacht
werden längst auch zivile ziele
beschossen
putins kriegserklärung offenbar zynismus
ziel ist es menschen zu schützen die
jahre einem völkermord durch das regime
in kiew ausgesetzt waren wir werden uns
für eine entmilitarisierung und
entnazifizierung der ukraine einsetzen
und diejenigen vor gericht stellen die
viele blutige verbrechen gegen
zivilisten begangen haben einschließlich
bürgern der russischen föderation
eine blutige lüge als auftakt zu einem
blutigen krieg
ich bin hauptsächlich müde und
verängstigt es ist ein ausnahmezustand
nichts davon fühlt sich real an keine
ahnung wie ich das in ordnung
eu-kommissionspräsident in ursula von
der leyen sagt heute früh nach stunden
der beratungen der eu staats und
regierungschefs dass der creme zur
rechenschaft gezogen werde man habe sich
auf massive sanktionen geeinigt die auf
70 prozent des russischen bankenmarkt
abzielten
unterdessen erlebt die ukraine eine
offensive wie sie europa seit langem
nicht gesehen hat
haben zuletzt die reaktionen des westens
gehört gehen wir jetzt nach moskau
sprechen wir mit unserem korrespondenten
christian senn in moskau christian wie
sind denn aktuelle reaktionen auf diese
geschehnisse auf den angriff in moskau
was ist denn aus dem kreml heute zu
hören
aus dem kreml gibt es bislang keine
informationen den ganzen morgen war es
eher ruhig da hat sich er das russische
militär geäußert das russische
verteidigungsministerium
wurden sozusagen die erfolge gefeiert
wie viele stellungen man jetzt zerstört
hat in der in der ukraine weil man ja
weiter hier auch bei der darstellung
bleibt dass es rein um militärische
ziele geht jetzt aber kurz vor dieser
sendung zum gespräch vor ein paar
minuten hat sich außenminister lavrov
geäußert ich kann das mal kurz zitieren
er sagt der russische präsident trifft
die entscheidung für diese
sonderoperation in der ukraine damit die
ukraine selbst bestimmen können und frei
von unterdrückung sind also das heißt
man bleibt hier beim narrativ dass man
eben das ukrainische volk befreien will
von dieser führung was man ja auch als
runter die man ja auch als runter
bezeichnet und die man mit nazis
gleichsetzt wir sehen wir wissen dass in
jedem krieg ist das erste opfer die
wahrheit gibt es auch einen
propagandakrieg insofern ist man muss
man mit zahlen vorsichtig umgehen aber
die ukrainische die ukrainische seite
behauptet die russischen truppen hätten
bereits schwere verluste erlitten das
verteidigungsministerium in kiew spricht
von 30 zerstörten russischen panzern 130
panzerfahrzeuge hätten die russen
verloren sieben flugzeuge sechs
hubschrauber und etwa 800 russische
soldaten seien getötet worden gibt es da
irgendwelche bestätigungen von
russischer seite
nein und ich glaube wir können auch
nicht davon ausgehen dass wir da eine
realistische bestätigung bekommen würden
es gab er gestern auch die metalle über
den abschluss eines russischen flugzeuge
da hieß es hier dann nach russischer
darstellung das sei mutmaßlich ein
technischer defekt gewesen also ich
glaube wir können nicht davon ausgehen
dass wir da realistische zahlen bekommen
die wir dann auch vergleichen können
ein krieg wird immer einen blutzoll
haben und zweifellos wir haben eben mit
lothar becker gesprochen wenn also die
ukraine wirklich am ende auch mit
molotow cocktails gegen panzer kämpfen
irgendwann wird es auch tote russische
soldaten geben wie ist denn die stimmung
der russinnen und russen in moskau wir
haben gehört gestern gesehen dass es
auch vereinzelt demonstrationen gegeben
hat in kleinen und viele festgenommen
worden sind wie ist denn die stimmung
wie ist die haltung zu diesen krieg
diese proteste sie haben es angesprochen
die gingen gestern im kleinen los und
wurden auch im kleinen mir schon
unterdrückt wir kennen das von anderen
protesten gegen die politische führung
in russland das oft versuchte die im
keim zu ersticken das heißt wenn sich
menschen treffen und sei es auch nur
kleine gruppen sind ganz schnell die
polizei wusste da und die menschen
werden abgeführt die proteste wurden im
laufe des abends dann immer größer
landesweit
gingen tausende auf die straße und die
letzte zahl die wir hörten dass es rund
1800 festnahmen gab das waren vor allem
junge leute die sich junge russinnen und
russen die sich sorgen machen um die
zukunft ihres landes und die richtung in
welche richtung sich das land entwickelt
das haben wir auch schon in den letzten
jahren hier gesehen als es auch proteste
für alexej nawalny gab dass viele junge
russinnen und russen auf die straße
gehen und viele wünsche haben richtung
freiheit und richtung weiterentwicklung
dieses landes und die sich sehr große
sorgen machen und gestern hatten wir
auch erlebt dass sich führende russische
journalisten zusammengeschlossen haben
mit einem offenen brief und diese
kriegshandlung verurteilt haben und
heute ziehen noch einmal andere
journalisten nach es gab jetzt nochmal
den aufruf von
wissenschaftsjournalisten mit einem
offenen brief da kann ich vielleicht
auch noch mal kurz daraus zitieren die
fordern die russische führung auf diesen
krieg zu beenden sie schreiben dieser
fatale schritt führt zu gewaltigen
menschenopfern sie sagen weiter für
diesen krieg gibt es auch keinerlei
vernünftige rechtfertigen und die
ukraine war und bleibt immer unser neues
land und sie stellen weiter fest mit der
entfesselung des krieges hat sich
russland zu ehren zu einer
internationalen isolation verdammt
präsent zum schluss nur noch eine
einschätzung also wir kriegen ja den
eindruck geben dass proteste kritik an
diesen krieg nichts ausrichten können in
russland nun hat der deutsche kanzler
scholz gestern direkt an putin
appelliert stoppen sie diesen krieg die
deutsche außenministerin hat direkt
putin angesprochen und gesagt ziehen sie
die truppen zurück stoppen sie also
diese angriffe diese militäroperationen
nun stehen aber panzer direkt vor kiew
gibt es irgendeine chance dass diese
ganze operation dieser krieg von putin
den er angefangen hat gestoppt wird
na ja wir haben das die letzten wochen
in wochen und monate erlebt dieser
diplomatische marathon zahlreiche staats
und regierungschefs außenminister wer
kamen nicht alles nach moskau zu
verhandlungen hat versucht auf vladimir
putin einzuwirken wir erinnern uns an
den besuch von von olaf scholz dem
bundeskanzler wo man danach vielleicht
doch die hoffnung war das gefühl haben
konnte dass es einen weg gibt für
diplomatie und dass es gleich wege gibt
sich irgendwie zu einigen alle wurden
enttäuscht diese diese wege gab es nicht
und die sind im moment auch nicht in
sicht und der einzige wo man vielleicht
auch noch jetzt zum schluss die hoffnung
hatte dass er irgendwie auch wladimir
putin einwirken kann also der einzige
westliche politiker das war immer eine
makro und man kaum hat gestern mit putin
telefoniert und das ergebnis war wohl
sehr ernüchternd also herausgekommen ist
dabei auch nichts dann vielen dank
christian seinem in moskau für dieses
bild von der russischen seite vielen
dank
auch in deutschland gab es am abend noch
eine ansprache des bundeskanzlers putin
wird nicht gewinnen war wohl die
deutlichste botschaft auch hier ist man
entschieden harte sanktionen gegen
russland volle solidarität mit der
ukraine die reaktionen aus deutschland
fasst jan fritsche zusammen
für die demonstranten gestern vor dem
kanzleramt ist klar was zu tun ist putin
stoppen mit maximalen sanktionen gegen
russland und waffenlieferungen an die
ukraine
eine ukrainische flagge auch im
kanzleramt doch viel mehr als
solidarität will der hausherr dem land
nicht zu sagen betont stattdessen in
einer fernsehansprache der krieg dürfe
sich nicht weiter ausdehnen
putin sollte die entschlossenheit der
nato nicht unterschätzen alle ihre
mitglieder zu verteidigen das gilt
ausdrücklich für unsere nato partner im
baltikum in polen und in rumänien in
bulgarien und in der slowakei ohne wenn
und aber
außenministerin bernburg wirft putin im
zdf-interview wahnvorstellungen vor sie
und kanzler scholz sein von ihm
angelogen worden daneben fordert die
grüne außenministerin eine bessere
ausstattung fürs militär
wir erleben aber wenn wir die bundeswehr
anschauen zum beispiel dass er mit blick
auf material natürlich deutlich deutlich
mehr machen müssen deutlich mehr machen
das sieht beim thema verteidigung auch
der bundesfinanzminister so in der
vergangenheit sei die truppe
vernachlässigt worden
es gab eine friedensdividende das heißt
wir hatten nach dem ende des kalten
krieges das gefühl das brauchen wir
nicht mehr andere übernehmen die lasten
etwa die vereinigten staaten die union
hat sich an tag eins des krieges hinter
den kurs der ampel regierung gestellt
nur beim thema waffenlieferungen gibt es
bei manch einem einen sinneswandel
es ist jetzt richtig weil nicht mehr
gesprochen wird dass auch deutschland
die ukraine durch lieferung von
militärischer ausrüstung unterstützt in
der deutschen politik hat ein umdenken
begonnen beim umgang mit autoritären
staaten doch für die ukraine dürfte das
zu spät kommen
wir wollen die reaktionen der deutschen
politik ein orte mit unserem hauptstadt
korrespondenten thomas reichert jetzt
zugeschaltet aus berlin welche
unterstützungsmaßnahmen plant denn
deutschland wenn der kanzler sagt volle
solidarität mit der ukraine
also erst einmal sind dass wir in bezug
auf die solidaritäts land für die
ukraine ist es der versuch durch
sanktionen
ausland da zum einlenken bringen noch
mal das ist so bei sanktionen ein
schwieriges schwert das hat sich in der
vergangenheit bei in den internationalen
beziehungen so gezeigt dass das nicht
immer gleich wirkt man muss ja nordkorea
oder an belarus denken die eu hat
gestern abend scharfe sanktionen
beschlossen
von finanzminister lindner hat heute in
paris beim treffen der eu finanzminister
erklärt das damit praktisch der gesamte
verkehr der banken röslers zum erliegen
komme
weitere sanktionen das ist nun die große
frage wichtigster auf dem tisch nach wie
vor muss man sagen gestern abend in
brüssel hat deutschland mit anderen
staaten sich dagegen gewandt dass
einzusetzen habe die diskussion in
deutschland in politisch von sollten der
union zum beispiel aber auch im konzert
der eu und insbesondere von den
baltischen staaten die ist da und es
kann sein dass es natürlich dann auch
heute nachmittag beim treffen der eu
außenminister in brüssel wieder eine
rolle spielen wird
thomas der ukrainische präsident
selensky hat sich sehr enttäuscht
gezeigt und seinen letzten
videobotschaften kritisiert vor allen
dingen in deutschland mangelnde
unterstützung das immer nur von
solidarität gesprochen wird er sagte in
dieser botschaft wir stehen völlig
alleine da wir können uns nur selbst
verteidigen weil die hilfe von außen
nicht kommt der ukrainische botschafter
in berlin hat noch mal deutlich heute
kritisiert deutschland und spricht von
einer kalten schulter die deutschland
zeigt ist das ganze gerechtfertigt
gestern spricht er kann da wieder von
voller solidarität aber dann kommt eben
ein punkt und nicht mehr
ich glaube dass die bittere wahrheit ist
dass die volle solidarität für die
ukraine vor allem eine ideale ist und
der versuch über
sanktionen druck auf russland auszuüben
die ukraine ist nicht teil der nato
geworden wie andere osteuropäische
staaten und ist nun nicht unter dem
schutzschirm von artikel 5 des
nato-vertrags der sagt ein angriff auf
ein land das ein angriff auf alle
anderen
bundeskanzler gestern in seiner in
seiner ansprache natürlich auch deutlich
gemacht dass da eine ganz andere
solidarität wirkt gegenüber den
osteuropäischen staaten zum beispiel
dabei klar dass sie sozusagen geschützt
werden dass deutschland da zu sein
bündnisverpflichtungen steht deutschland
hat angekündigt dass es zum beispiel zum
schutz der in südost flanke der nato
weitere drei eurofighter nach rumänien
auf den luftwaffenstützpunkt konstanter
verlegen wird um den luftraum an dieser
südostflanke weiter zu überwachen in
verbindung zum beispiel auch mit
italienischen streitkräfte
deutschland hat auch schon die mitte
februar
seinen sein truppenkontingent in litauen
in dieser sogenannten battle group
litauen erhöht um 350 soldaten aber
natürlich wenn man sich das anschaut wie
viel soldaten jetzt präsident biden nach
deutschland noch eine extra verlegt 7000
dann wird es ein verschwindend geringer
anteil
da zeigt sich einfach dass die
bundeswehr insgesamt auf eine solche
krisen situation nicht gut vorbereitetes
der heeresinspekteur hat gestern alarm
geschlagen hat gesagt dass her steht
praktisch blank da
die bundeswehr ist in gewisser weise der
ausgeblutet und es ist weiß ich jetzt
auch als hypothek das in der
mittelfristigen finanzplanung zb die
olaf scholz als finanzminister noch zu
verantworten hatte der haushalt vorsieht
dass die mittel für die bundeswehr in
den nächsten jahren abschmelzen werden
jetzt hat man in berlin da ein gewisses
umdenken es wird also wahrscheinlich
doch am ende mehr mittel für die
bundeswehr geben in den nächsten jahren
aus diesem schock denn diese invasion
hier
in berlin auch ausgelöst hat aber
natürlich das dauert alles seine zeit
bis diese bundeswehr wirklich
eingerichtet ist dafür eine bedrohung
wie sie russland und im moment darstellt
das wird natürlich eine ganze weile
dauern
vielen dank thomas reicher wir haben ja
auch eben gehört herrn lindner und auch
die außenministerin berbalk die hat
deutlich gemacht haben dass sie einsehen
die bundeswehr die truppe ist wohl
vernachlässigt worden und man muster
mehr tun vielen dank für die
einschätzungen thomas reichert in berlin
dann wollen wir weitergehen nach brüssel
thomas reichert hat es angedeutet dort
werden auch weiter entscheidungen
getroffen sprechen wir mit unserem
brüssel korrespondenten gunnar krüger
gunnar welche auswirkungen sind denn
durch die bisher beschlossenen
eu-sanktionen überhaupt zu erwarten
wir haben ja heute
die sitzung der
nato-botschafter zur stunde und diese
eu-botschafter beugen sich über die
beschlüsse des gipfels aus der nacht wir
waren etwas überrascht dass der gipfel
eigentlich ja mit relativ schnell mit
schlussfolgerungen kam aber dann sich
doch bis in die nacht zog und ein grund
dafür wird gewesen sein dass man sich
eben über swift nicht einig war die
amerikaner sprechen das ja auch ganz
deutlich an amerika die für einen das
vereinigte königreich und auch einzelne
europäische hauptstädte die wollen
durchaus dass russland aus dem
internationalen zahlungssystems hüfte
ausgeschlossen wird aber es sei eben
noch keine europäische position also die
europäer würde diese position nicht
mittragen und da stellt sich natürlich
die frage wer der bremste und warum und
eben weil das eben auch auswirkungen auf
die europäischen mitgliedsstaaten haben
kann der österreichische kanzler kam
heraus und sagte dass die aussetzung von
swift wahrscheinlich für die russische
föderation gar nicht so viele
auswirkungen hätte wie für die
europäische union argumentierte so
russland habe sein eigenes
zahlungssystem und es könnte sich auch
ganz schnell einem chinesischen
zahlungssystem anschließen soll also
heißen dass swift dieses dieser ausdruck
auch eine einer westlichen
wirtschaftlichen dominanz hier vor den
toren von brüssel dass das dann dadurch
geschwächt werden könnte dass man sich
also selbst schädigen könnte das mag
stimmen aber das ist auch ein relativ
bequemes argument weil gerade
österreichische banken stark in russland
investiert sind die könnten der
zahlungsausfälle befürchten dass geht
frankreich auch so dass geht italien
auch so andere staaten die wickeln
gerade ihren zahlungsverkehr um das gas
zu bezahlen das aus russland kommt über
swift ab da hieß es dann eben kein swift
kein gas aus russland also das wären
schon sehr heftige
rückwirkung auf die eu und da gab es
daneben zögerlichkeit bisschen gibt es
aber auch kritik also hier auch im
europäischen parlament kritik sogar aus
den reihen der ampel ein grüner
abgeordneter sagte wir zahlen mit
unseren gasrechnungen ein teil dieses
angriffskrieges dann sollten wir auch
bereit sein ein preis dafür zu zahlen
damit das aufhört solidarität das kostet
eben oder wenn damit also diese
uneinigkeit in der eu doch deutlich wird
sind denn dann überhaupt weitere
sanktionen denkbar und welche könnten
das überhaupt sein über die hinaus die
wir von denen wir bisher gehört haben ja
also am montag wurde ja sozusagen dieses
erste paket verabschiedet erster teil
des pakets verabschiedet das ist ja seit
donnerstag in kraft und dann kam eben
dieser großflächige angriffe auf die
ukraine dann wurde eben gleich das
zweite paket diskutiert auf dem eu
gipfel gestern
da steckt eben nicht drin jetzt könnte
man sich vorstellen wenn man dem kanzler
glaubt dass er sagt für einen späteren
zeitpunkt möchte man sich das
aufbewahren dass daneben sich darin
steht dass russland tatsächlich
ausgeschlossen würde von diesem
zahlungssystem man könnte sich auch
vorstellen dass dann die
personenbezogenen sanktionen also das
einfrieren von konten und die einreise
stoppst dass das dann auch putin und
seine sein umfeld sein direktes
familiäres umfeld auch direkt treffen
könnte denn bislang wurden zwar viele
leute aus dem machtzirkel von putin mit
solchen sanktionen belegt aber putin
selbst nicht das hat man bislang so
begründet dass man eben weiter mit ihm
auch verhandeln
können will und das ist dass er bislang
ausgenommen wurde das wäre ein denkbarer
nächster schritt wie ein weiteres
sanktionspaket
also das dilemma die möglichkeiten und
die offenen fragen die in brüssel
herrschen vielen dank herr krüger für
diese information ja wir wollen wieder
in die ukraine schauen die genaue
militärische lage dort ist ein bisschen
undurchsichtig präsident selensky hat in
der nacht in einer video botschaft
mitgeteilt die ukrainische armee habe am
ersten tag der russischen invasion
137 soldaten verloren 316 soldaten seien
verletzt worden russland habe das
gesamte gebiet der ukraine angegriffen
die ukrainische führung rechnet glasklar
mit einem panzerangriff auf kiew die
us-regierung sieht das genauso der
amerikanische außenminister blinken
erklärte kiew könne womöglich belagert
werden ziel des russischen präsidenten
putin sei offenbar die prowestliche
seelands die regierung zu stürzen aus
der ukraine selbst erreichen uns viele
bilder einen überblick nun über das was
wir aus dem land erfahren von christof
bock
kiew heute morgen in diesem wohnviertel
der ukrainischen hauptstadt ist eine
rakete eingeschlagen
die städtische feuerwehr ist vor ort und
versucht zu löschen
innen sieht es jetzt so aus viele
wohnungen sind zerstört ein bewohner
berichtet
es gab einen knall etwas für über uns
ich kam zum fenster und sagt zunächst
nichts nach der explosion hatte ich von
dort einen guten blick ich konnte sehen
wie fenster teile von beiden seiten
herunterfielen zum glück wurde niemand
verletzt
ein amateurvideo zeigt wie das wohnhaus
in der nacht den flyer steht die nacht
und der frühe morgen in der
millionenstadt wurden von lauten
explosionen zerrissen immer wieder
raketen beschuss die ukrainische armee
gibt an zwei davon im flug zerstört zu
haben immer wieder sirenen die die
ukrainische zivilbevölkerung in der
hauptstadt den schrecken und todesangst
versetzt tausende haben schutz gesucht
den u bahnhöfen
wir waren nicht darauf vorbereitet zu
fliehen niemand hatte mit dem
kriegsbeginn gerechnet und dass sie
direkt angreifen würden
man wusste in der panik gar nicht wohin
und wie man sich verhalten sollte die
menschen unter schock ungläubig viele
versuchen zu fliehen dass der andrang an
den grenzen zu den europäischen
nachbarstaaten im westen bisher nicht
noch größer war mag daran liegen dass es
vielerorts schwer ist voranzukommen seit
dem gestrigen morgen rollt die russische
militär offensive von mehreren flanken
diese rakete schlug in einem wohngebiet
von kiew ein was haben die ukrainischen
streitkräfte dem entgegenzusetzen der
präsident organisiert nach eigenen
worten aus kiew heraus den widerstand
seine worte ein verzweifelter appell
ich habe 27 staats und regierungschefs
gefragt ob die ukraine in der nato sein
kann ich habe direkt gefragt alle haben
angst keiner antwortet mir
am späten abend hatte er eine allgemeine
mobilmachung angeordnet russland hatte
behauptet nur gegen militäreinrichtungen
vorzugehen doch nach den worten des
ukrainischen präsidenten aus der nacht
werden längst auch zivile ziele
beschossen putins kriegserklärung
offenbar zynismus man bringt er die für
ihr ziel ist es menschen zu schützen die
areale einem völkermord durch das regime
in kiew ausgesetzt waren wir werden uns
für eine entmilitarisierung und
entnazifizierung der ukraine einsetzen
und diejenigen vor gericht stellen die
viele blutige verbrechen gegen
zivilisten begangen haben einschließlich
bürgern der russischen föderation
eine blutige lüge als auftakt zu einem
blutigen krieg
ich bin hauptsächlich müde und
verängstigt es ist ein ausnahmezustand
nichts davon fühlt sich real an keine
ahnung wie ich das das einordnen soll
eu-kommissionspräsident in ursula von
der leyen sagt heute früh nach stunden
der beratungen der eu staats und
regierungschefs dass der creme zur
rechenschaft gezogen werde man habe sich
auf massive sanktionen geeinigt die auf
70 prozent des russischen bankenmarkt
abzielten
unterdessen erlebt die ukraine eine
offensive wie sie europa seit langem
nicht gesehen hat
aber jetzt nach washington schalten zu
unserem korrespondenten elmar theveßen
aber ich hab es eingehen schon gesagt
die us-regierung befürchtet eben auch
geht davon aus dass russische panzer
eben in der ukraine vorrücken immer
schneller vor allen dingen auf die
hauptstadt kiew zu wie reagiert denn das
weiße haus darauf auch das pentagon auf
diese neuesten entwicklungen
ja zunächst mal sagt mann im weißen haus
das hat auch der präsident ja bei seiner
pressekonferenz sehr klar gemacht das
haben wir ja immer gesagt das klingt
natürlich jetzt zynisch aber es ist
genauso die usa haben seit oktober
letzten jahres den aufmarsch beobachtet
sie haben alle verbündeten in europa in
der nato darüber informiert und zwar in
einem nie gekannten ausmaß da wurden
geheimdienstinformationen geteilt alles
was in bezug auf die grenzlinie zu
kleine passierte alles was
möglicherweise auch an operationen
sogenannten false flag operationen
vorbereitet wurde all das wurde im
vorfeld von den amerikanern
weitergegeben und sie haben auch genau
dieses szenario weiter gegeben dass sie
angesichts dieser riesen streitmacht von
erst 100.000 150.000 jetzt
175.000 soldaten mit all den elementen
die dazugehören davon ausgehen dass es
nicht darum gehen wirklich nur einen
teil der ukraine ein stückweit
abzuspalten oder komplett abzuspalten
sondern dass es ja all-in heißt wie man
so sagt das heißt russland will die
komplette ukraine einverleiben und dazu
gehört auch die installation wie man
hier in washington sagt dann ist
marionetten regimes in kiew deswegen
hatte man auch in den letzten tagen rund
um die münchner sicherheitskonferenz wir
erinnern uns pläne entwickelt wie man
herrn selensky den präsidenten entweder
bitten könnte gar nicht zuerst zu kommen
weil das risiko zu groß war dass ihm auf
dem heimflug nach kiew etwas zustößt
oder eben auch pläne zu entwickeln wie
man die regierung wie man allen voran
präsident zielinski möglicherweise
evakuieren könnte um sicherzustellen
dass man dann eben von außerhalb der
ukraine
die eigentliche regierung weiter haben
kann ohne dass es russland möglich ist
vielleicht das was ich abzeichnen könnte
in den nächsten tagen oder wochen und in
moskau ja auch angekündigt wird ohne
dass es irgendwelche schauprozesse oder
gerichtsverhandlungen gibt gegen sie
lenski und mitglieder der regierung also
die amerikaner waren die man hier sagt
kleid sie haben alle ihre verbündeten
auch entsprechend instruiert und vor
diesem hintergrund spielt natürlich die
sanktions diskussion eine große rolle
hätte man könnte man mit irgendwelchen
noch weiteren gegnerin sanktionen
verhindern dass kiew in die hände
russlands fällt beim militärisch da ist
man hier mittlerweile von überzeugt dem
pentagon in weißen haus lässt sich nicht
verhindern dass die russischen
streitkräfte kiew übernehmen und dann
eben solch eine marionettenregierung
installieren biden hatte im weißen haus
gesagt putin ist der aggressor und eben
hat sanktionen angekündigt vielleicht
können wir die noch einmal
zusammenfassen die vorbereitung ist
gesagt sie hat einst die usa wussten was
passieren würde haben sich ja auch mit
sanktionen vorbereitet und die sind nun
sozusagen diese karten gezückt worden
vielleicht können wir die noch einmal
zusammenfassen
ja vielleicht einmal vorweg die usa
verteidigen natürlich auch dass sie die
sanktionen die ganz harten sanktionen
nicht schon früher verhängt haben es hat
auch ein stück weit damit zu tun dass
man natürlich der diplomatie noch eine
chance geben wollte er hätte man die
sanktionen vor wochen verhängt dann wäre
sofort jeder diplomatische fahrt
verschlossen gewesen man kann man sagen
putin hatte sowieso nicht vor sich
irgendwo auf eine diplomatische lösung
einzulassen weil es ja extremforderungen
und vom ersten tag bis zum letzten tag
im gegenteil die wurden sogar noch
erhöht gegeben hat also sanktionen
früher zu verhängen so die sicht des
weißen hauses hätte die lage nicht
verändert hätte sofort im grunde
wahrscheinlich zu einer eskalation
geführt weil der diplomatische fahrt
geschlossen während dieser aktion die
dann verkündet worden sind zum einen
gegen die größten russischen banken das
ist wichtig weil diese banken für
russland und die russische wirtschaft
wichtig sind denn wenn sie vom
internationalen zahlungsverkehr
ausgeschlossen sind wenn sie sich nicht
geld in anderen teilen der welt besorgen
können dann gibt es innen
wirtschaftliche probleme in russland die
größte bank die sberbank beispielsweise
ist dafür verantwortlich die gehälter
und auch die renten für etwa die hälfte
der russischen bevölkerung auszuzahlen
also es schneidet russland von den
internationalen finanzmärkten ab es gibt
natürlich eine rücklage die russland
gebildet hat hat die schulden verringert
hat ihre reserven angelegt also wird das
eine weile abfedern können aber es ist
schon eine sehr harte sanktion das
zweite sanktionen direkt zielgerichtet
gegen die chefs dieser banken gegen auch
die chefs einiger großen energiekonzerne
dazu ihre familien das heißt ihre
guthaben werden eingefroren niemand darf
man mit ihnen geschäfte machen auch das
nahrhafte sanktion aber unterhalb dessen
was man hätte tun können zum beispiel
putin selber auf diese liste setzen
können das dritte in sanktionen
beziehungsweise
exportkontrollen ein verbot von exporten
von hightech gütern an die russische
hightech industrie und das betrifft vor
allen dingen den rüstungssektor die luft
und raumfahrtindustrie in russland
russland braucht für die modernität
seiner armee aber auch für viele
technische entwicklungen künstliche
intelligenz quantum computing und
ähnliches amerikanische mikrochips
software technisches gerät
technologisches know-how das wird nicht
mehr kommen das weiße haus sagt etwa die
hälfte dessen was russland an
technischem gerät und
mikrochips und ähnlichem bekommt wird
künftig nicht mehr geliefert werden also
insgesamt was russland an importen von
diesen waren hat weil auch die eu mit
zieht das wird die modernisierung
russlands deutlich erschweren und das
ist auch aus sicht der amerikaner und
der europäer ein harter schlag es hätte
noch einen vierten geben können und das
wäre der energiesektor war bis auf die
tatsache dass man einige anführer von
großen gas und ölunternehmen
gasunternehmen tatsächlich auf die
sanktionsliste gesetzt hat ist nun
diesen schritt nicht voll gegangen will
also die öl und gas flüsse nach
westeuropa nicht unterbrechen da hätte
man noch luft nach oben und wir haben es
vorhin ja auch aus brüssel gehört die
große diskussion um swift hätte man
russland aus dem bankenverbund ganz
hinauswerfen sollen aus swift oder
hatten wir eine sehr spannende
diskussion gestern beim briefing im
weißen haus mit der pressesprecherin
john key und wir sind mit dem eindruck
zurück geblieben das ganz offenbar die
regierung hier aber auch die europäer
die ja vor allen dingen nicht wollten
dass swift gestoppt wird dass man also
russland rauswirft aus diesem verbund
der für die transfers von von geldern
rund um den erdball zuständig ist
deshalb nicht weil man sorge hat die
sage die lage zu sehr zu eskalieren das
hat der partie nicht explizit gesagt
also im sinne von
dass es dann zu einem großen krieg
zwischen der nato und russland kommen
könnte hat an zwei stellen in der
pressekonferenz also gesagt also
unterhalb davon einen dritten weltkrieg
zu haben oder unterhalb davon dass
russland einen dritten weltkrieg
produzieren kann an zwei stellen so
gesagt sind das für uns hinweise darauf
dass man auch wenn die europäer vor
allem den geblockt hatten und die
amerikaner swift also diese option
gezogen hätten dass man doch
zurückhaltend war weil man ein stück
weit sorge hat dass putin weiter
eskalieren könnte bis zu einer art
weltkrieg und diese annahme basiert eben
auf dem was putin in den letzten wochen
gesagt und getan hat er gilt im weißen
haus als unberechenbar jedenfalls nicht
mehr als ein rationaler gesprächs
haben es gesagt us präsident biden hat
deutlich gemacht die ukraine ist nicht
in der nato die usa werden also keine
truppen in die ukraine schicken kurze
frage wie wollen die usa dann einerseits
die ukraine jetzt noch unterstützen und
wie wollen die usa die östlichen nato
partner die balken polen etc
unterstützen wo ja nun auch eine gewisse
sorge vor russland noch größer geworden
ist
ja für die ukraine war der plan a das
man weiter gelder gibt um die
ukrainische regierung zu unterstützen
dass man auch waffen und munition
liefert so weit das noch möglich ist und
dass man drittens auch aufklärungs
informationen liefert die man aus
satelliten überwachung und ähnlichem hat
angesichts der lage auf dem boden
ehrlicherweise all das wird der ukraine
nicht mehr viel helfen die russischen
truppen stehen schon in den vororten von
kiew und man geht davon aus dass diese
option nicht mehr wirklich nützlich ist
die zweite option von der hier immer
geredet wurde eine art guerillakrieg in
der ukraine zu unterstützen also wenn
sich ukraine finden die tatsächlich mit
geringer taktiken versuchen wollen
ähnlich wie ich sag das mal schräger
vergleich aber trotzdem der wird hier
angeführt vital www die mutter ideen in
afghanistan gegen die sowjettruppen in
den 80er jahren unterstützt worden sind
solch ein gerät krieg würden die usa mit
waffen mit munition mit informationen
unterstützen ist natürlich eine extreme
option
und das würde sicherlich auch russland
weiter provozieren also die optionen
sind gering und ehrlicherweise glaubt
hier niemand daran dass ernsthaft die
usa innerhalb der ukraine große
militärische hilfe noch leisten könnte
und das andere ist die verstärkung der
ostflanke der nato da hat man ja nicht
nur in den letzten tagen noch einmal
nachgelegt also soldaten aus italien ins
baltikum verlegt kampfhubschrauber und f
35 kampfflugzeugen aus deutschland an
die ostflanke der nato verlegt sondern
dass in den beiden hat das gestern
angekündigt es kommen noch weitere
soldaten noch weitere ausrüstung 7000
zusätzliche soldaten
das ist vor allen dingen eine eine
panzerbrigade eine kampfbrigade die
verlegt wird nach deutschland um die
ostflanke der nato zu stützen und die
nato berät ja eben auch heute darüber
wie sie strategisch auf diese neue
herausforderung
reagieren will mit russischen truppen in
der ukraine möglicherweise diese
komplett besetzt und einem anführer im
kreml der mindestens so unberechenbar
ist wie die anführer zu zeiten des
kalten krieges
vielen dank für die informationen aus
washington und auch die einschätzungen
el mati wissen danke nach washington
wir haben es eben von unserem
korrespondenten aus brüssel gehört dass
putin sich eine gewisse
sicherheitsoptionen schafft und zwar die
zusammenarbeit mit china eine gewisse
absicherung zum beispiel auch
finanzieller art und weise beide sind
nicht direkte partner aber doch
autoritäre regime und insofern gibt es
gewisse gemeinsamkeiten und könnte es in
dieser krise einen zusammenhalt geben
zumal der gegner gemeinsam ist der
westen putin war bei der eröffnung der
olympischen winterspiele in peking hat
den chinesischen machthabern getroffen
deshalb schalten wir weiter zu
christiane hoffmann nach peking und
fragen dort nach christiane welche
reaktion gibt es denn in china
in china beobachtet sicherlich sehr
aufmerksam die geschehnisse und hält
auch kontakt zu russland und präsident
putin und überlegt sich sicherlich wie
stark ist ihm den rücken stärkt und
weiterhin den rücken freihält heute hat
der chinesische außenminister war nie
mit dem russischen außenminister lavrov
gesprochen und aus den informationen die
wir haben ist lesen lesen wir dass china
weiterhin hinter russland steht und
weiterhin die nato als den eigentlichen
aggressor sieht denn die nato hat sich
entgegen
vereinbarungen so ist die lesart fünfmal
richtung osteuropa ausgeweitet und damit
vereinbarungen mit russland gebrochen
gleichzeitig wird in diesem gespräch
ging es wohl offenbar um eine forderung
die aufgestellt wird einen balancierten
sicherheitsmechanismus in europa zu
schaffen so lesen wir dass und das heißt
für mund- und da auf dessen grundlage
sollen dann verhandlungen stattfinden
und übersetzte verstehe ich das so dass
putin die ukraine in seiner
einflusssphäre zurückholen wollen will
in die russische einflusssphäre und erst
danach mit den europäern verhandeln
möchte und mit dem besten der nato in
den usa und
das wenn das so eintreten würde wäre das
natürlich besonders bitter für die
ukraine wir sehen bei der christian da
hinten auf dem bildschirm ein treffen
von putin und kiwi ist denn eigentlich
die beziehung zwischen den beiden zu
beschreiben
der die beziehung scheint doch recht eng
zu sein präsident putin und sie haben
sich ja kurz vor beginn der olympischen
winterspiele vor drei wochen hier
demonstrativ getroffen und eine allianz
besiegelt
gegen die nato und gegen den westen und
man kann davon ausgehen oder sie teilen
auch gewisse gemeinsamkeiten
sie sind autokratische führe die auch
ein ähnliches regierungssystem haben und
die auch begriffe wie demokratie und
menschenrechte
nach ihrem gutdünken
uminterpretieren und gleich gleichzeitig
haben sie den gemeinsamen gegner das ist
die usa und die sehen sie nach analyse
von beobachtern derzeit als schwach an
und im niedergang und in einem in einer
erklärung die sie im februar
veröffentlicht haben dieses man brauche
einen neuen führer für die welt und
offenbar fordern sie jetzt hier die
ukraine nicht die ukraine natürlich
sondern die usa heraus und wollen da
offenbar neue
eine neue in richtung einer neuen
weltordnung vorstoßen gleichzeitig ist
china aber auch in einem dilemma denn
china sagt ja für sich nimmt für sich in
anspruch zu sagen wir sind ein
souveränität und nicht einmischung in
die angelegenheiten eines staates sind
sehr wichtig und auf der anderen seite
will china sicherlich nicht seine
wichtigen wirtschaftsbeziehungen zum
westen komplett
ruinieren und deshalb wird china
sicherlich genau beobachten wie stark
der die sanktionen sind wie geschlossen
der westen auftritt und wie lange man
putin den rücken stärken kann
bevor dieser krieg ausgebrochen ist hat
mancher china-kenner beobachter auch
gesagt china wird sich genau anschauen
wie der westen reagiert wie es läuft
wenn putin wenn russland sich die
ukraine einverleiben will und weil china
mit einem auge auf taiwan schaut kann
man das so sagen wie es spürt man dass
sozusagen in peking
china beobachte hat sicherlich sehr
genau abzuschätzen welche sanktionen der
westen jetzt macht
gegen russland um zu sehen wie der
westen reagiert wie die usa reagieren
und sicherlich haben sie da ambitionen
das auch mit blick auf taiwan und sie
werden daraus schlüsse ziehen allerdings
zu sagen es hier analysten ist china
militärisch noch nicht in der lage
richtung taiwan zu gehen und
gleichzeitig hat china ein wichtiges
jahr vor sich oder die chinesische
regierung denn im oktober möchte sich
präsident ich hier in einem beim
nationalkongress
lebenslänglich auf lebenszeit ernennen
lassen und daher ist dieses jahr für ihn
doch innenpolitisch auch sehr wichtig
und da ist die frage ob man
vorher richtung taiwan schaut
hoffmann vielen vielen dank für die
informationen für diese zusammenfassung
der des blicks auf chinesischer seite
vielen vielen dank
schauen wir jetzt wieder in die ukraine
wie der russische einmarsch in die
ukraine bisher genau ausgesehen hat
gleich von drei seiten aus haben
russische bodentruppen angegriffen zum
einen vom norden von belarus aus
angriffe auch aus dem separatisten
gebiet also von osten her und von süden
von der halbinsel krim
wir können jetzt sprechen mit dem
ehemaligen nato general egon ramms
general führt und morgen
einen wunderschönen guten morgen
wie beurteilen sie die derzeitige lage
und welches verhalten erwarten sie von
der nato
also wir müssen zuerst mal festhalten
dass die informationslage die ist jetzt
gibt zurzeit keine gute informationslage
ist einfach aus dem grunde weil es keine
offiziellen mitteilungen keine
offiziellen angaben von seiten der
russischen seite gibt das ist ein
schwachpunkt
bei der ukrainischen seite sieht es
etwas anders aus aber auch da wir nennen
das als soldaten den nebel des krieges
fock auf wo sind die meldungen die
nachrichten mit sorgfalt zu überprüfen
und erst wenn sie bestätigt werden
entsprechend zu zu haben trotzdem zur
lage im augenblick scheint so zu sein
dass der angriff der von norden erfolgt
relativ erfolgreich bis an die
randbereiche von kia vorangekommen ist
was mich wundert ist dass wir aus dem
osten im raum blick relativ wenig hören
deutschland der russische angriff nicht
so erfolgreich zu sein und aus dem süden
der angriff aus der krim raus ist offen
sichern angriff gewesen der die ukraine
überrascht hat war noch für sich nicht
mit diesen auch mobilen und gepanzerten
kräften nicht gerechnet hat
zum zweiten teil ihrer frage was hat die
nato zu erwarten wir haben gerade gehört
und wissen dass die nato in erheblichen
bereichen
truppen die usa nach europa verlegen
dass die nato ostflanke insgesamt von
estland bis runter nach rumänien und
bulgarien entsprechend verstärkt wird
von daher hat die nato eine position
eingenommen bei der man sagen kann wir
weisen die russen darauf hin dass wir
verteidigungsbereich sind und dann
bleibt letztendlich die hoffnung dass
nicht unglücklich zwischenfälle und
dergleichen mehr hier irgendwelche dinge
passieren die dann möglicherweise doch
zu einer weiteren verschärfung der lage
auch im verhältnis russland und nato
führen könnten jetzt haben wir das
gesehen sie haben es ja auch gerade
zusammengefasst angriff von drei seiten
drei fronten krieg aus ukrainischer
sicht von norden von osten von süden her
die truppen so kriegt man den eindruck
stehen wirklich wenige kilometer vor
kiew die us-regierung hat auch
entsprechende information sieht das
wirklich danach aus dass russland
tatsächlich möglichst schnell die
kontrolle über die hauptstadt bekommen
will damit sozusagen den kopf auch der
strategischen streitkräfte der ukraine
kontrollieren will und damit den krieg